yo I'll [ __ ] it's echoing [ __ ]
we're alive no we're not yeah we are
[ __ ] okay
yes um hello hopefully you can hear me
um
[ __ ] hell let me just double it it's
echoing [ __ ] is it it's a delayed at all
how's my lips
how's my lips moving it's a good [ __ ]
out all right so uh we're gonna play
some games go play some games if you're
watching this offline for some reason
check out the link in description it
will take you to when we actually start
playing meanwhile we're gonna that's not
I just get excited and get some people
in here people are still saying they
can't hear me a bit of delay it
shouldn't be
you
offer for sake god damnit I quit I quit
it's such delay on the stream so like
it's really hard to get direct input you
should hear me now stop talking we can't
hear you
hey ghost dogs what up I yield night
gaming year preciate you you calling me
stupid I got a lot of questions of
people asking how you become a sponsor
well let me tell you you go to gaming
dot youtube.com slash PewDiePie there
you can become a sponsor if you want to
have like their looks captain logo or
whatever and so that you can chat I'm
noticing how I am wearing green as well
don't worry about it this is my real
background everyone um next next super
chat that's red decides what the
background will be Julian Ambe can you
shout out to my channel a URI
ai-ai-ai-aight you re what a great
channel you have IRA I really just
appreciate the name in general it's a
very good name and I'm I wish you all
the best
ok crazy for love you so much Pierce
Thank You Adam Skinner hey they're from
Australia
I swear everyone that uses a super chat
is from Australia am I like always
streaming on else tray Lea High Times or
some [ __ ] love me the out last season
definitely best so far that's cool I'm
glad you enjoying it I figured everyone
this moved on from the game so far Robyn
Courtney heya they're loud and clear
hello from the Philippines PHP meme
Batista what's going on with all your
demonetized Asian Chelsea
apes uh it seems to a gun from zero to
like 10 percent pretty much hey I see
you're budgeting sponsor showing up I
guess I worked and thank you guys
appreciate all of you and so yeah it's
it it's slowly improving from from from
nothing so I'll take it but right now
I'm making fuchal cashier bail more
again hi Felix you're great I had
internet for like eight months so I have
a lot of cat oh you didn't have internet
for eight months a lot of catching up
today sounds good man welcome back or
woman sorry kemar hey pills have you
seen a save PewDiePie's show site we
made it to support you Kim are don't
amusing no uh no I have not saved
PewDiePie Peter guys show calm 91,000
signatures that's so sweet
I'll sign up I have to use a fake email
I guess signing up to this [ __ ] boy from
the UK that's very nice thank you guys
appreciate you um I I think it just
needs time we just it just needs time
and then people will get over everything
that happened James Oliveros make the
background blue well I
you're not red so I'm sorry Emily Crosby
you're always online late at night for
Aussies was up 3 M I appreciate you guys
staying up for me guys again how are you
your Aussie nurse here why do you have
to stream when I just start a night
shift god dammit
please make the background blue can you
look at my channel in your spare time
I'll open a tab for your channel and
I'll make it blue why blue uh Elliot is
nesaf Australia again Australian bros
men what can I say hello from Spain our
trucks my big chase
yo yo yo sup pip I Love You Man hey I'm
a crappy music shout-out to my channel
I'll I'll check it out
all right we're playing my big cheese
right now
[Music]
sounds alright sounds like you're
jamming out keep playing I'm sure you'll
get better I like the the effect you had
on your guitar sorry I'm trying to
change the background to blue okay
sorry one second guys the multitasking
is not a not on point here um background
macro background where did I save it
pictures
whoops hey it's blue how about that what
did this stream go I actually closed you
guys like I'm the worst streamer ever
I'm sorry hold on one second we're gonna
play some games if you have anything
planned today I it's time to cancel it
because I'm going to be swimming for a
long time today all right we have what
up boots DS ik back get it again also
work in that night ship one night shift
do you guys work as committee tour all
teapots are used yeah I'm probably gonna
read I it because you can see like it's
already growing out which i think looks
alright
peers can visit Russia I will just
scared of getting [ __ ] in the ass
hello from me sorry I had to beat a
child for this money so he felt like it
thank you
I love from Canada it's five it Jessica
white what the [ __ ] go to sleep Jesus
Christ you guys are not else inspiring
me search on my own channel Megan Taylor
thank you that's so nice
sappy demon what's up man you're the
best world keep up the good work
love you sexy thank you you guys are
sexy to notice me daddy
I'm noticed you and no MS my dad left my
mom for a fourteen-year-old younger
gross he left us one week before
Christmas my mother was seriously
suicidal lip hat
sorry the past ones super difficult by
your videos got me through them sings
Brophy time it's better now by the way
this music is not fitting these comments
at all
sorry uh I'm really glad my videos help
dude and I'm glad you made it through
some tough times that's really cool ah
whenever we're never time too tough
sitting through it you'll you'll be
stronger afterwards I really think so
so that's come on and even bad
experiences can be a good learning thing
I guess I don't know I'm not a [ __ ]
coach shoutout from Brazil Brazil
appreciate you Patsy Patsy what a great
name
[ __ ] it's going too fast guys slow down
please please keep your shibai ha ha ha
what up 50/50 piston might see a watch
broken a picker yet no and then she's
never gonna watch it can you comment my
name is Jeff there you go I need your
fenced I need your fans to believe me yo
also thanks for having my channel I'll
make memes for okay thank you Kyra
senpai appreciate you ah [ __ ] it's going
too fast I'm kind of ketchup on the
aisle el Brad Ford Pitt's my boyfriend
I'm watching religiously it's almost
feels like you're our secret best friend
ah that's cool
appreciate you love you and Marta and we
did smash your pass on you would you
watch it okay I'll check that out that's
funny I [ __ ] terabrite games thanks
again appreciate you how are you doing I
will I will definitely roast the [ __ ]
out of you was that defeat hey bro shout
out from Canberra straight Australia I'm
gonna have to restart my my thing um if
you guys wonder how you get the chat
thing go to gaming calm slash sorry
gaming gaming dot get not gaming calm
tech god damnit day gaming dot YouTube /
PewDiePie and then there's a sponsor fun
turtle champs how you doin
Hillary Clinton hey Larry Clinton for
turtle chip I need to upload so I can't
stick around for too long just wanted to
leave a message and give you some more
support I'll make sure to come back
after uploading going going to be a
little nightmare episode this is dope
cane let's go I'm loving the game as
well thank you so much turtle chips um
I'm gonna I'm probably play some later
as well good luck with that mr. n arcade
I have terrible news I grew it grace
which game and stole my beard in the
night grow the beard pits grow it for us
I'm growing it can't you tell it's
coming along quite nicely I would say
kawaii chubby kid kid what's up from
straya is that Estrella short for
Australia I don't know Puetz it's 6 a.m.
in Texas go to sleep what are you no way
how come the color doesn't change from
300 to 500 shake my head I guess I won't
send you I didn't see I didn't see you
send it I can see all the red ones what
are you talking about I'm sorry if I
miss
bambam McGee hey boots you're awesome
shout New Zealand what are you guys
doing over there go to sleep finger the
soundboard for me that was a bit loud
Lowell Jolie it's my birthday it's
volleyball today
oh [ __ ] mall boy is like the biggest
drinking day in Sweden we're gonna have
to get the whiskey out later I think I
have some Swedish whisky actually this
is sick this is blink-182
we literally just spent the last five
minutes talking I'm watching Ellie
Bradford oh cool
I'll sub to you guys Channel it's a dope
mix turn they're like so
[Music]
so I'm getting a message it's making
sure uh also I'm not streaming neckla
today if anyone wonders because we want
to make sure everything is working
properly and we're having some
difficulties it looks [ __ ] awesome
though we got like this I want to show
you guys later the [ __ ] system
Caribbean [ __ ] Oh
[Music]
resting peace the SpaceX launch google
it what happened I've no idea what
you're talking about
lobby bro GG white thanks man love you
PewDiePie from Australia oh great late
yeah what's that but hey Pitts thank you
for making videos to inspiring me to
start doing YouTube death the genome
that's cool man appreciate you good luck
with your death genome it I'm going to
make Dark Souls 3 that purposely run
some training for hints for a second
like Blighttown in Dark Souls 1
Blighttown is the worst [ __ ] part of
any video game I have ever played good
luck with that [ __ ] hey pills I'm always
making my always making my day much
better Thank You Cameron short
appreciate you you just made my day a
little bit
hey Pitts oh god it's going so [ __ ]
fast appreciate all of you ok let's
start
get into game soon because I can't keep
up with you guys read this and I'll
build your spaceship skull room
appreciate it let me know when my
spaceship is ready scauldron robin lewis
looked like there's like it's
susie-wusie easy up here another
youtuber here great work man dig your
vids thanks Robin um I don't know what
there was easy I guess what coz thing
I'm gonna have to look that one up
what's the suck thing bhakti could you
follow me on Twitter I'm sorry that's
too much going on right now hype it's
always hyper your stream here's a little
small support appreciate Alexandra I
wants for you Alexander no way take it
back
take it back I retracted it sorry
good luck next time it's it's 1:21 p.m.
in Denmark yeah yeah you want ahead one
hour ahead of me
David's a zebu lovey pills you dumb man
all the way from Australia oh right I
want to go to Australia I never been six
paths of rain true fan since I stopped
watching your stop watching your game
place what are you talking about and
come back when you content change Lowell
can you make him look at my movie
trailer also when rice makes that disc
call call me because I'll help you
destroy him that's all right I don't
need a ghostwriter and what the [ __ ] is
this trailer you me check out six paths
of a rainin Lisa O'Sullivan preciate you
king of burrito I recently had to mental
illness craziness with hospital things
from Australia for being a laugh
everyday I hope you're doing better king
of burrito where is family-friendly
Felix playing Jesus Felix you need to
put hercules disappoint on your son but
i have that i took it away I changed it
to that one this love what she says that
it's beautiful
hey Felix can you say my name the way
you say PewDiePie how does it go dressed
this is sweet
did too
today we're just gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
got it
Keter sent by nope it's you read my
message wrong I meant comment it on my
last video what was I supposed to
comment on your last video [ __ ] I don't
remember expected since it can be
considered a slice of life I don't know
sorry alright it's going to are you a
pills I send you some batteries for your
birthday when the mornings going to kick
go along bed Rhys
thank you super yeah hey I'll look up
for the game
alright guys hold the break I'm gonna
play a game I won't be looking at the
super chat unless it's a red or anything
like that
so hold your horses if you guys want to
join the chat you can become a sponsor
go to gaming dot youtube.com slash
PewDiePie on this there should be a
sponsor button there let's play some
[ __ ] outlast I want to finish this
game I'm gonna to refresh cuz Thank You
Adam Rogen appreciate you how you guys
doing today good old good ol Sunday good
ol streaming day thank you for joining
the stream everyone you ready for some
outlast is anyone not sick of this game
yet I just feel like it got so
oversaturated now like certain type of
content is so big on YouTube ah that you
can't keep up anymore unless you upload
everything day one I'll be guys on mine
I would burger like why would she
comment
let me just set up one guys I hope you
don't mind me eating a little snack I'm
gonna stream a long time today and I
need energy whoa holy [ __ ] salat times
them if you read this can you do a
shout-out to my sister and
brother-in-law going through a lot of
their new baby going through a lot with
a new baby at the hospital
Congrats Nicole and Jody Congrats Nicole
and Jody nice baby names Tiberias that's
a cool name
we call him our little super saiyan cuz
he got a lot of fight in it that's cool
I hope it's a healthy baby and I hope
hope y'all doing good
that's amazing Congrats Nicole and jute
that's awesome are you straight hummus
no I'm extremely gay honestly I love
dick what can I say alright let's turn
off this [ __ ] boy right oh my god Patsy
big Patsy
Patsy says sing me a song like those
hentai girls what do you mean
hentai girls I'm never doing that again
[Music]
thanks for that batsuit James olivera's
react to the sex offender shuffle what
the [ __ ] is that
Damon jerk I love you dad alright not
much to preach at all that's right sorry
I gotta we got games to play let me just
add the game um is a Game Capture um
display capture maybe no window capture
[ __ ] I don't know what is [ __ ] I got
a knot in my throat that sounded weird
haha I'm gonna choke to death on the
stream whoa what happened there oh why
is it not uniform scaled what the [ __ ]
hi guys it's me hey guys welcome to the
live stream oh [ __ ] hey hey guys welcome
[ __ ] what's the right resolution now god
damn boy how does this look am i right
in this corner should I be in the other
one that's too much [ __ ] going on there
alright guys if you want to join the
chat you to a gaming dot YouTube sorry
we're going to repeat that gaming
youtube.com slash beautify you can watch
the stream there and you can become a
sponsor
hopefully the chat won't become too [ __ ]
sorry I hate I hate people eating on on
the footage but it's a streaming I guess
I saw that you guys are saying left
corner left corner right corner Bluebell
indeed did you hear about blame having
an anime yes
I'm so [ __ ] excited it's a movie
though it's not a series it looks really
cool I love how it ties in with Knights
of Cydonia with that what the [ __ ] is a
call the beam blast or whatever the gun
he has it's the same one the same
universe it's so cool
the cannon whatever [ __ ] I forgot the
name no one gives a [ __ ] alright what is
it coming out
huling in cemetery what smells Kesha
bula hi oh my god got her holy [ __ ] I
will cut my hair bold and record it if
you help me reach for K more subs what
the [ __ ] alright sub to god er everyone
just google got her there should be an
anime panda face and he will cut his
hair bald you should shave it ball
through it now alright you guys ready
let's let's play let's play some games
hope let me know if you want the games
to be louder dude be a little louder
alright we're continuing off here
ah bad a race yes alright here we go
let's take it easy now hopefully I won't
suck so much ass like last livestream
it's [ __ ] painful like that I was do
you get 100% of the donations no YouTube
takes 30% thanks thanks you too it's a
cool service I really I really enjoyed
this stream did a good job there's a lot
of improvements that can be made but I
think they're gonna do it Hey look I'm
getting shot that guy got [ __ ] a
mouse cub jesus [ __ ] christ got a
heel what the [ __ ] I was I was covered
what that was [ __ ] don't look don't
look
zero depth zero deficit [ __ ] right I got
to run up there it is like an [ __ ]
what is he shooting from their nest
everyone mods please I beg of you try
and do a good job of sensory because I
seem like a lot of people popping in
here we go go go go ah how are you doing
buddy
he's bent over that's yeah it seemed
kind of much yeah what is he doing no
get away from me get away from me you
disgusting ah what the [ __ ] it's a
problem is everyone prob gonna slip that
off a head back there are you kidding me
are you kidding me get up get up
all right I need to get out of here [ __ ]
how many Jeff laughs on why is
everyone's such a [ __ ] [ __ ] are
you kidding me
how does it ha-ah disgusting pero des
terreaux death row got her I'm [ __ ]
got her good luck good luck with that
you should shave your balls Nix as well
I mean everyone should clean balls are
the best okay why do I die from this
[ __ ] little [ __ ] that's ridiculous
okay let
this is ignore him there we go
hello from Australia sorry I'd literally
just uploaded my first video on YouTube
everyone check out no komak and support
his first video le no men zero dad Thank
You Ellie at least sorry can't [ __ ]
read kiss there you go just right back
let's keep playing run run run
[ __ ] Drago up here what does he have to
shoot me
yes bandage take it take it you can't
[ __ ] I can't [ __ ] Oh cheats ok oh the
[ __ ] no stop stop I'm wiggling you're
not gonna [ __ ] get me
I'm sick of dying of [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
my god is sclerotic
what the [ __ ] is that big ah [ __ ]
ah I'm having a bad day man oh hi you
it's ok
we have you wait you're supposed to kill
me the gospel isn't [ __ ] Mortal
Kombat ripoff
what restriction what zero dams shut up
now three dams good sinker ten
am I getting buried alive right now
great all I ever wanted visit Australia
you cut thanks buddy
maybe I will maybe I will they're doing
a [ __ ] job at bro okay never mind I have
a little spoiler for you guys for the
scare PewDiePie episode we did outlast
and Ken was the guest and he got to be
buried alive it was really [ __ ] cool
and I was supposed to bit dig him out uh
I won't say too much it's just it was
funny I was supposed to dig him up but
as soon as I realized it was Ken I was
like a [ __ ] ha ha so at school they
stayed true to the game that's really
awesome
what's supposed to break out I can't do
anything tap just tap repeatedly if
you're ever hey how about that if you're
ever getting burned alive just tap
repeatedly I always think of that Kill
Bill when she does that you know the
fake superfish I braaap braap we're fine
I don't know why you're so freaked out
about that that was fine I can't see a
[ __ ] single thing I wasn't your bad
batteries batteries oh oh [ __ ] it's a
slug [ __ ] snails men oh [ __ ] off [ __ ]
off you [ __ ] snail Blaire waters
pills hype it's love you love you back
what is this I know hi there's my no
[ __ ] off [ __ ] off man [ __ ] off oh my god
he moves man I don't look at him what an
[ __ ]
stop
okay here we go huh stop ah [ __ ]
they're everywhere
[ __ ] they're everywhere go go go go
go go go
gasps go yeah ah [ __ ]
ah get move [ __ ] swamp monsters go
yes yes much just sorry
people hate when I use the thing too
much well that's too bad [ __ ]
it's too fun
I'm like a kid bad dreams when the my
own names go we have so many [ __ ]
batteries now I could start a battery
business honestly I think out less was
better I think I let's to better
I think the DLC was the best though the
outlets DLC whistleblow there that was
the best but I think this is way more
polished oh my god I Cisco I'm not even
gonna bother and it's more interesting
hey just hanging around are we buddy
that's cool
welcome a mustache but if you guys want
to become a sponsor just go to gaming
dot YouTube / put a path it's a simple
as that should we watch this video maybe
I forgot how you did it even Chris okay
go find my way to the mine alright let's
look at this amazing fetish sylph before
I could stop her or she did it no wait
not her what are you what are you
smoking about [ __ ] he's mixing her up
with Jessica Annie
the game sucks because you always get
lost and it's always running I can see
that what's a lot of being chased in
this game it's fun though at least it's
not like completely dependent on jump
scares like so many games are it's like
sure they have them but it's not all
they have right I think the chase factor
is more interesting than jump scare
Godard got it thank you for the picture
man dude my favorite game right now
persona 5 I'm loving playing it I don't
know
sar Fox 64 love that game your mind
you're shaving your balls get out of
here am I supposed to go down here ah
[ __ ] it seems like a really oh why
didn't you warn me okay we're gonna do
have to do an epic jump here are you
guys ready can we get some epic music
that's not epic that's not epic that's
not Hillary Clinton I really don't have
any epic [ __ ] music whatever let's go
ahh Wow
wasn't even epic so I don't know why
I've even [ __ ] hey look a stick
I love sticks don't tell max either [ __ ]
sorry I had to take the rub from from
his pulley that's what she said hell
yeah
it's called castration or is it who
knows
family friendly Felix all right wait who
the [ __ ] is that what a [ __ ] is a it all
right let's take it carefully zero
deaths by the way there are depths this
is a zero def playthrough Felix are
excited for Uncharted and lost leg Z
wait they announcing you and charted oh
boy oh no oh my god
like look at that skinny [ __ ] I could
punch the [ __ ] out of that [ __ ] like
honestly I'll punch right through him
I get it you're not a fighter but
sometimes it would be nice Nemus key hey
Peter started my channel two months ago
we'd love a shout-out tamekia good luck
to miss Kier all the best can I come in
please
hi hi am i disturbing something oh
that's oh that's okay
I was nearly got away got her oh not now
got it
3k more subs okay well got her everyone
sub - got her so he doesn't get poor
just let me out let me go let me go -
night [ __ ]
[Music]
miss miss Milan she UK thanks buddy
appreciate you wait this is where I came
from [ __ ] it is I need a rope okay now I
need know what I need to hang myself
that would be good no never do that
unless you're a nut checkout line oh
they're all this here [ __ ] ass ah ah I'm
Sarah never zero deaths zero deaths
every one zero deaths top of the morning
to you zero def playthrough of outlast
that was clearly a troll angel 20
appreciate you
trolley angel 20 everyone okay let's
find some rope Huck
yeah yeah all right rope we need some
rope where's the rope
help me they help me in the comments
please I don't want to be stuck here
hey do you have some rub oh my god it's
question motive taking a [ __ ] boy up and
[ __ ] oh my god is a skinny [ __ ] no I
got it I was gonna say March day but no
she that's me
das us Jesus Christ 400 from das I stood
for [ __ ] her she sets [ __ ] toys
- a step I will suck your dick call me
please let me hit you up I'll take you
out for dinner we'll have a great time
I'll do whatever you want my body is
yours thank you man or woman that's
amazing hey we got some bandages that we
don't need [ __ ] where's the rope sure no
you're not in mind is my house lock the
door
thank you my house in the middle of the
street
ah [ __ ] bad [ __ ] [ __ ] Hey
why does everyone want me what do I do
what the [ __ ] I can't what the [ __ ] is
happening
stop just stop just stop everyone stop
[Music]
alright let's go in here
sure nothing bad is in here and let's
heal because we're going to zero def
playthrough
where's the [ __ ] rope guys they break
down [ __ ] doors faster than I can
break down my own you know what I'm
talking about
where's the rug where's the rope what
the [ __ ] are you doing there ah Sarah
des bah what's out last about well
that's a it's a live Arizona simulator 0
- we did it well Jesus Christ
the girl what do you mean the girl that
ash boy look it's you guys the Rope is
by the hanging okay so we got to find
the guy being hanged what [ __ ] camp
I'm trying to pick up you guys comments
Dave Grasso baby holy [ __ ] thanks plan
zero deaths there left all right
oh there it is okay how do I get it down
rune [ __ ] off
no don't touch me there's no rope here
ah Sh
maybe need to go off [ __ ]
ah yeah
holy [ __ ] you guys [ __ ] it help lilit
that fun beautifies my second most
favorite youtuber not being assaulting
what I love what you make root who's
your favorite who's your favorite then
huh
you better not say Jax but I see Thank
You lead I remember you really
appreciate it
that's alright it's okay to like other
youtubers I only see I don't care
you can like more than one youtuber how
about that that's a lie by the way full
online I'm at Betty big cow zero Depp's
alright
don't [ __ ] touch me I think I know
where we need to go or why are there so
goddamn many of you alright here we go
there's to be a mountain pass yeah go go
go there it is
got him that's my rope now Wow
oh no I gotta go and get it [ __ ] ah [ __ ]
Oh leave me alone
they're on at no Sarah [ __ ] leave me
alone please you can't come to my house
I have no bandages come on man let's get
the bandages and get the [ __ ] out
there's the rub there's the rub
[ __ ] get the rope get the rope get the
rough cut the rope get the rope got the
rope I hope what alley you come from I
can't see anything
Oh oh [ __ ] the right there oh [ __ ] oh
hey how you doing
run run run run run run run run run
straight straight straight straight
ah hey nay paddle back that [ __ ]
oh that's annoying my people got stuck
in my ass Sarah des
ah wait I have oh I have the rope
Oh how's that can you stop stop
you can't hit this you can't hit this
like you can't hit my mom's ass Oh Sara
death Sara deaths everyone's top of the
money to you [ __ ] okay maybe it's not
going that great okay maybe maybe we've
died I stressed I'm stressing you guys
out because I can't do it all right well
I'm so sorry what do you think I feel
let's take this route stop [ __ ]
shooting me how about that strength
strength you get this ah
oh gosh [ __ ] hell yeah hell yeah what a
save dance put the rope Gabe hauling
tape it's I've seen your Slenderman bit
a few years back and I've been a fan
ever since state rail Gabe haulage thank
you so much appreciate what a school you
guys support me for so long
Oh [ __ ] are you don't I hope he dies
please die no yes yes push up push up Oh
God
what's happening
happy Volvo everyone from Sweden don't
drink too much
[ __ ] my ass is asleep O'Shea he's dead
haha got him hey yeah sexy now I can
finally have my sexy time
you should sneak in the grass around and
use the microphone or I'll find my way
to the mine or I can just strafe what do
you think I'm not pro at this game
excuse me
my dad died within a month my mom he was
perfectly healthy until she was gone and
oh come on man I didn't need your life
story [ __ ] my ass is asleep I need to
sit on a pillow or some [ __ ] I've been a
fan since your gay porno thank you guys
I really appreciate if you guys don't
mention that time all right I'm trying
to move on to bigger things now deshaun
respawn official hey pills prove your
challenge expedite C [ __ ] made me want
to start a channel my own hopefully I'll
be able to grow a community as friendly
friendly as yours that's cool man it's
cool to see you guys starting your own
channels shell Shawn respawn official
how the [ __ ] do I get out of here
appreciate you guys we found the mines
or is this a memory this must be a
memory
oh god what the [ __ ] is that sound
oh my god what was that the game dude
doesn't give you a chance to breathe a
lot it's more like hey you're getting
[ __ ] you're getting [ __ ] and now hey
guess what now you can [ __ ] - this looks
cool
looks like we can get up there it's
really interesting because like you can
jump anywhere in the game and you don't
you're not used to that in games I guess
if you guys want to help out with a chat
I go to gaming youtube.com slash
beautify and you can hit the sponsor
button or whatever that way you can chat
and you get to become an hour loop skip
to how about that this where I'm
supposed to go gutter I have to go
thanks for the stream still at 3k subs
from shave my head got hurt
you're the man you the man I wish you
the best I'm gonna I think I'm
subscribed to you already but I'll sub
to you just so that dude what are you
talking about all you need 90 K is that
it you'll get there
no problem
um okay maybe here
No
[Music]
got er everyone stuck together
okay we're Barbie you burp like edgar
farts thanks guys appreciate it Ramez
let's go it's so dark here oh [ __ ] that
was obvious
I can't tell if I'm walking in circles a
night I really can Oh what is happening
we're in the school now aren't we
why would we ever want to go back in
that [ __ ] hellhole
great
have you Romans anyone in persona 5 yet
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
well I just romant someone in this game
Jesus Christ zero death I haven't gotten
that far in persona is there a right
answer that thanks for getting me
[ __ ] kill there where did it come
from
oh my god I get it
we need to jump down here
[ __ ] that's creepy oh my god I'm so
[ __ ] creeped out
go go go go go go go go [ __ ] just go no
oh my god
whew that legit scared me Oh Oh Tim
Higgs 50 haip it's your great youtuber
love your vids go buy a bottle of
maker's mark I will i 100% we appreciate
your tip I'll have a drink in your
honour mate later on Allah in the last
hours of today I'll pop out some whiskey
if you guys want to hang around for that
long oh my god [ __ ] okay we need to find
out where to go it all looks the same to
me out on Adam Skinner hey Pitts I'm
going to sleep now
[Music]
I'm going to watch the rest of your
stream in the morning but can you give
me a my brother Brendan a shout out from
Australia go to sleep Australia thank
you so much Adam Skinner shout out to
your brother Brendan how you doing
appreciate you alright let's keep going
I need oh there's a hatch here isn't it
hey I found it how about man I don't
know why I bother going back into this
[ __ ] hellhole but you know top of the
morning - we haven't seen our girlfriend
in a while I wonder what's happening
with her how if you guys have already
finished a game how long do you imagine
there's lat
left of the game like 80% 20% radial
mutant been watching a bit since 2008
sorry that's KP drag I can so much love
you only
oh my god it's coming oh my god [ __ ]
Rachel I'm sorry Jesus Christ open how
is this thing always after me ah
Raziel is that your name Reza Freya it's
alright but I appreciate all the support
of comets batteries
we're nimona known in the Netherland
well I feel like it gets worse every
time we're back in the cafeteria now oh
my god
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
oh my god Jessica here Jess hey oh god
this is so creepy pun little one light
of light Jesse this here me and Chad
wrong uh uh presents right here if that
one year Jessica can you kind of quick
taste oh god the Sun look time pun
little one okay
light of light I can't use the light and
[ __ ] on this is so dark I need not fear
if that one year okay Blake oh yeah oh
yeah they're just please oh oh my god
nah oh oh [ __ ] we got about four hours
to go okay that's cool what's the
recharge
imagine if there's a glitch in the end
oh you can go Jessica Jessica Jessica
you mean like that oh my god
zero deficit one we got zero death this
whole playthrough it can't believe it
I'm so proud to the other side of Lake
okay we have a new mission new mission
get to the other side of the lake boys
legit almost dropped my laptop I was an
intense [ __ ] jump scare all right
it's always funny when you guys comment
are you from Arizona and you're like
let's just exactly have a taste Felix
finally someone understands their
struggle this is cool
the lake is wrong everyone that [ __ ]
does that mean
what I am what am i filming calm it
laddy loving in your cellar content oh
my god I just got a lot of let's read
them out while we play this movie who
like right doesn't seem to work Bobby
new style continent inspired me to my I
do my own channel however YouTube has
decided that LGBT and satire channels
like mine have become a dead meme I need
all the help I can get lot stream to
call me laddie check out call me laddie
I'm curious what kind of stuff you're
making that's cool I mean it's not cool
it is it's not like I'm hoping that with
time they will adjust their system with
all the flagging or whatever I think
right now it's sensitive times
it sucks for everyone honestly I really
appreciate all the support and doing
times like these it's really cool to see
and I think that's why I love doing
these streams as well because you guys
are so nice ah I almost died the water
is wrong everyone what the [ __ ] does
that mean
should we do some fishing
why why is the sound doing that what's
in the water what's in the water guys I
hate water
lyrics rape please subscribe to all my
other channel Marc CAC CAC so gamers
need 5000 subs Marc Axl gamers sounds
might like America
Sokka I'm sorry I don't know why okay so
that's long what about here is there
anything in here some note
I don't know man go in and swin really
really guys that's your tip go for a
swim
shut up I'm not going to her swim you
guys are [ __ ] crazy
I'm going with a boat
uh-oh look close that door
the [ __ ] something's up here something's
afoot the raft go where everyone is like
go in the lake and swim shut up I'm not
gonna do it oh wait someone donate 150
where don't see we talked about sorry I
don't want to I don't miss any big ones
I'll be an [ __ ] alright so we unlock
this house the creatures in the water
yeah no [ __ ] [ __ ] that's why I'm not
going in the water but what's in the
house I'm getting Resident Evil 4 vibes
well the thing the thing that I like
about Resident Evil is that it starts
off super scary right but then you get a
gun and you can kind of fight back which
is the exchange is a dynamic I think
there's too much of the same here
a little bit that would be my only
criticism oh god oh yeah yeah but
all right I'm I'm making sure that I'm
going in the water as my last [ __ ]
option
all right maybe we can swim like really
fast batarangs play hydraulic quit what
hey from Dan Mike can you give me a bro
Victor shadow shout-out to Victor all
right we can go let's just go whoa
swim swim swim swim swim swim swim god
no no don't need help no don't need help
no I've made a terrible mistake I am so
sorry
[ __ ] oh I just get pulled down oh oh
what the [ __ ]
zero des that was just that I just
fainted I do that every time I don't die
[ __ ] token water
lake is wrong I'm not stepping a toe in
the water well I don't see any other
option
I don't
where am I going oh there's a wooden
draft yeah I get that but where I don't
see it
look they're all broken new everyone's
like there's about to the right which
left and which right are you talking
about what are you guys smoking okay all
right so I'm looking forward now left or
right now go left or right
meanwhile Tim Higgs honestly I piss on
just like someone to watch my crappy
bits Tim Higgs check out Tim Higgs
everyone it's got a pink shirt and only
five subscribers now you got six buddy
whoa holy [ __ ] honey thank you so much
Jason Momoa can cosplay hey Felix just
want to say love what you do your videos
helped me grow a lot and learn not to
let constantina hate get to me also wish
I could have seen scare pewds as yandere
chan just made you pretty we did there
was a yandere simulator episode actually
but yeah that some doesn't make things
thank you so much there was a younger
age simulator episode with Jessica Nigri
it was a very bizarre day very bizarre
day i legit got super pissed at Jessica
at one point because she kept [ __ ]
hitting me with an eel because the
producer kept telling her to do it and I
was like Jesus Christ this [ __ ] is
crazy
she won't stop it was super fun though
she was a super cool that Bears act desk
hahaha she's a cool desk
Jessica's cool desk everyone shout out
to Jessica Nigri best desk of all time
oh my god guys Kara Cruz hundred jesus
[ __ ] christ hey piers been watching
your vids in 2011 when I was a freshman
it's been six years since and then and
now married with a beautiful baby boy
that's amazing congratulations Kara
every time I watch your bids I feel like
I'm hanging out with a longtime friend
proud of you my Tia love from gwaan
that's amazing it's such a nice comment
such a generous donation thank you so
much Chris Shay that's so cool
still haven't got an answer you're all
wrong you're all left where's the raft
oh my god for Preston hedges hey Felix
wanted to ask you if you ever seen or
heard of my hair Academy I want to watch
that also can you hit that knee knee
knee button for me hell yeah
X the Fox what's up rose can we get 1
million donation of this video on the
side of when the [ __ ] comes in Sweden
you fat [ __ ] below much love for fire
support what this one able to cover your
me mum diction thank you appreciate jet
I haven't had a meatball in so long I
have it every time I go back to Sweden
because they are so much [ __ ] better
in Sweden I'm trying to read the chat ok
right just line the water you will see
it ok
it's not this one where is he been
where's the [ __ ] ramp where's the
[ __ ] raft guys all right I'm playing
all right I'll take a break here
is it you know keep going right I am
maximum right I'm [ __ ] maximum right
what are you guys talking about
it's so annoying when Pitts doesn't know
how to go ok well give me some less
chillies direction it's pretty hidden
the raft is a lie look up the mountain
here this is where I came from now well
now you're saying left for [ __ ] sake
you guys are [ __ ] [ __ ]
can I get you to say to subscribe to
rube see everyone subscribe to rube C
best channel on YouTube will spank my
ass for oopsy okay I'm trying to listen
to you guys directions but they're so
shape
let me check the house again
here we go is this it this could be it
oh that sounds lovely let's go there
here we go follow the water yeah [ __ ]
right the [ __ ] are you guys smoking
[Music]
what's happening here oh my god zero
deaths
zero deaths everyone okay I'm putting on
a [ __ ] tool that water
okay I know I know where to go now at
least [ __ ] man it sucks getting stuck on
a live stream and this game you get
stuck a lot because it's like never
really obvious where to go and like it's
so [ __ ] dark as well we just got I
don't want to ignore the really big ones
hi Phil --ax I live in the first Zoo and
rescue center for McDonald's in Denmark
and create a game that helps charities
like sue I've been trying to send you a
private video can i PM you you can email
me on my about page that sounds really
cool though sounds like a good
initiative alright let's find this
[ __ ] ramp I wasn't even supposed to
find the raft yet guys are such [ __ ]
[ __ ] best best best chat best chat
ever you guys are the best
I love you guys so much thank you for
all your help
what is happening to my body 300 [ __ ]
subscribe to mashaallah subscribe to a
shell everyone everyone goes subscribe
to mashaallah best channel will will
spank my [ __ ]
am I supposed to do this jump I think I
am you guys are [ __ ] crazy Wow
zero deaths everyone someone just wrote
don't jump down my fiancé Mike and I
look forward to watching your videos
every day we're wondering what's your
current favorite meme is I don't know I
don't know hook yeah that's my favorite
name that's cool it's cool to see like a
lot of couples watching me I think
that's awesome mean might say watch a
lot of youtubers together as well it's
great this place seems great I'll I love
this place
oh what a great place Fanta jesh when
the mornings gone you can't go on beta
juice when you wear a thong and it
really it's true friend what are you
filming all the time
I don't care what is filming all right
so now we're you can find they're after
you guys were confused before keep going
right draft a head for cereal yeah you
better be for cereal you best be for
cereal cuz I'll be Kelly Ariel lucky do
new cross raft now we can find the
[ __ ] wrap let's go bro
here we go umm sailing away set an open
course for The Verge and see my blue
I've got you be free free to face
tonight and that's ahead of me I'm bored
I'm the captain so climb aboard
well search for tomorrow which way
should I go this way and I'll try oh ha
ha
try seriously where do I go I thought
about a game like this where you you
play it on the PlayStation or like VR
and you have to rule row with your
remotes and then you have to look around
through binoculars so you hold them like
this and then your headsets becomes
binoculars and you have to look out for
sea creatures kind of like a snap hybrid
so like you have to find them while at
the same time moving towards your goal
and then like [ __ ] creepy mermaids or
some [ __ ] would attack you
and then they they could pill you fully
we got her back with the money's got it
what the [ __ ]
I feel like I'm becoming goddess [ __ ]
because you donated like a [ __ ]
fortune all happy I will happy be your
[ __ ] which way do I go
paddle oh I heard something wouldn't
that be a cool game though and then the
second part of the game you go down
underneath the ocean that's my little
game idea please don't steal it like it
oh [ __ ]
what what was that
so like you would go underneath the
ocean and then the goal would be oh my
god we got dead fishes to find like
what's the name of that exercise
biblical giant collects hope the God I'm
just losing my [ __ ] I refined dead
fishes hey they're just hunting with
dynamite
great well it seems like out leister
already did what I what I didn't want to
do oh my god where's my raft oh [ __ ]
go go go go go no I don't need a help
oh so creepy it's really cool
the sacrifice is about to begin with a
[ __ ] designer Wilson well said we did it
I'm sailing away get in the raft yeah
what do you think I'm doing guys I feel
like I'm the worst at paddling doesn't
even look like I'm pedaling does it
all right we're making it to the other
side there's something about the deep
water that is just so [ __ ] creepy
because you don't know what it's in have
you guys ever like swum in the middle of
the ocean there's something about it man
something creepy about it yeah I'm glad
we don't capsize I used to be a sailing
instructor for like little kids and we
would during my week we had like the
worst [ __ ] storm ever but we still
have to go out and all the kids the
first day all the kids were like who
wants to sail with Felix and I was like
yeah maybe me me me me me but then we
would just capsize so [ __ ] much that
by the end of the week it was like who
wants to save the Felix just completely
silent I was like ah no one likes me
little real-life story for you guys no
one gives a [ __ ] I get it
the [ __ ] is this path dude you're the
worst paddler man how long are we going
to be on this [ __ ] boat this is
someone image F [ __ ]
well at least I'm stuck I'm [ __ ]
stuck the [ __ ] why do you hate Australia
I don't hate Australia are you talking
about I despise Australia
got him
what's in the [ __ ] water
ow poor excuse for a quote it's not a
boat it's a raft you [ __ ] [ __ ]
ha [ __ ] come on ha
[ __ ] ah looks like come on looks like
we're gonna have to swim all [ __ ] we did
it
press money yeah yeah how's everyone
doing this Sunday those were the ones
who took Lynn we're gonna be screaming
for a long time so buckle up boys
I'm almost barely okay we're fine now
you're dead good Christians piers is now
my [ __ ] got on since goddamnit got it
Herod 16 you want her to have the baby
my god they too and there's no baby
I have to
now you realize you have to get your
girlfriend what the what the [ __ ] man
got a legit like donated more than I
made on YouTube this week seriously what
the [ __ ] god
oh great that's fine okay not oh another
one what a nice little place whoa banker
es3 stava
okay I have to go study big exam but I
love you love you too boo Carrie I
probably kill your chair name but thanks
for watching okay
don't get caught thanks for the tip guys
you're being very helpful as always all
right we got this [ __ ] they're out
looking for me aren't they
fireballs note they lit someone on fire
and then they drop them in there please
help me get a few thousand subs love you
bro Jessa Troy check out Jessa Troy
everyone help them out all right this
this [ __ ] raft is lasting a long time
man code rehearse less you can crush a
Wall Street Journal in hydraulic press
channel game hydraulic press pocket you
should see it wait what they do that I
got to check that out thank you so much
by the way Josh sure noticed you
am I going the right way
I felt like we're getting speed I don't
like this
Oh God oh [ __ ] oh no oh no no well said
oh this is bad this is real bad this is
real bad
wait I'm fine I'm fight [ __ ] the raft ah
[ __ ] the raft will be there ah [ __ ] the
rat we're after for [ __ ] am i right
it's like a kpop lay from my ass
wow you guys are mean just cuz I love
kpop doesn't mean you guys get to cyber
bullying me yeah where is it right where
I can't oh just
I don't like this oh geez
the setting reminds me of that [ __ ] what
was that movie with Leonardo DiCaprio
[ __ ] no oh hey it's just as
good hello it's a family party it's fine
it's nice
nice little place you got here I like it
some effigy Zach gaming hey bro can I
get a shoutout I watched you from your
happy wheels states love you loads from
Zach check out Zach Zach gaming everyone
top of them on champ
if you guys want to use the chat just go
to a gaming dot youtube.com slash
goodbye alright let's find a way to get
a [ __ ] cross here oh my god I'm
getting so many super chats let's hide
here meanwhile we got a [ __ ] thousand
dollars Jesus Christ
Ellie Bradford it's my boyfriend is in
his office watching you while I'm
watching in my bedroom please tell
Durham Jeremiah he is the second best
guy in the world only guy I would marry
besides number one which is we just
gained like 17 subs in two months proud
that's amazing your channel looks really
cool
the mas family adventure hey piers is a
dream come true to see you live Ellis a
would be a dream come true if you can
shout my channel art we do daily vlogs
and family challenges well I hope you're
not like daddy or five if you're not
like daddy or five check out the moss
family adventures Jay plays hey longtime
fans leverage channel could you have my
channel get shout at Jay plays check out
jay place and in the mosque family oh
five i'm skidding okay let's keep going
how do we get across
[Applause]
there must be a better way up here I
hear someone up there I feel like we're
supposed to lead rock BD rock gaming
who's my son I loved your a believe dog
just as much as your game videos keep up
the good work
shoutout to BD rock gaming you guys are
so nice I'm trying to focus on the game
a little bit though just give me a
moment alright because I'm [ __ ] stuck
again that tree looks like a hand
should I just go down don't go
the revenant that's it that's more of a
shaky cam though please don't jump in
the water okay I won't I just don't know
where to go it's a note here hey top of
the mornin G okay that was fun
what the [ __ ] where do I go I'm always
stuck in this [ __ ] game here it is
[ __ ]
there's always something [ __ ] ironing
isn't this where I came from though oh
my god it is for [ __ ] sake
find the raft the raft is right there we
just need to get to it come on we can do
this Poots it's obvious shut up it's not
obvious stop cyberbullying me it's still
alive no it's not I just hear someone
where's it coming from
where do I go the ledge
hey put it by it's hardly your favorite
large epic Jew what will you be a crater
summit again no I wasn't invited
let's skip class and go to the movies
the YouTube Sun was really cool I don't
think it was invited this year that's
completely on me because I may have done
some things while being drunk that I
shouldn't have done so but I have a good
time at the summit it was really fun
last year the good old summit I may or
may not have peed from the building
that's all I'm gonna say about that okay
where the [ __ ] do I go cross the river I
don't think so
let's try it
early 30s 30s oh we missed ha ha ha ha
the road s0 - okay I'm so not see we're
still not dead because I didn't die I
can still make
[Applause]
they're just okay so we just go farther
up the river yeah we just need to swim
better
[Music]
okay let's say triangle I'm swimming
this way as much as I can come on come
on come on come on it doesn't work
push a tree okay that would make sense
thank you guys for helping me I'm a
[ __ ] idiot the tree on the effigy
that would make sense
I just don't know how I'm still not dead
okay the wrapkin the gunfire I can
stomach no there is a tree okay
correct Christian Medina thank you love
you Christina media media maybe read
that
[ __ ] no okay I'm glad I'm not
the only one confused so playing this
game because [ __ ] hell
there it is there's the [ __ ] tree yes
love Jesus I love him it's the best he's
so good no no what
how do you [ __ ] that up what the hey
that was that was a glitch that was a
glitch I don't know what happen or I'll
radicular oh these nuts are good
um
if we both spam just timed them out
please
I do my teachers hanging
I got a lot less scary older son Harry
we got the rap Lucy with clover thank
you so much losing
[Applause]
biggest gamer in the world everyone shut
up shut up
oopsie
holy [ __ ] we got a 200 donation jeez
Whitney words are hard you always been
there when people need someone to keep
them afloat well I need just like I need
the RAF right now you affect your fans
more than you know been watching a year
for years I'm so happy to see how far
you've come always do what you love and
their support would be ah you guys are
so nice
mayn't use so much Whitney that's so
cool appreciate you
wait what's that a thought what's it a
thousand five hundred NT Lucy with
clover what's that NT what currency is
that I got a Google a because that's
very confusing [ __ ] is empty okay okay
it's it's 0.033 it's a new Taiwan dollar
I was like holy [ __ ] a thousand five
hundred it's it's a it's it's fifty
dollars
I certainly appreciate about like if it
was a thousand I wouldn't want to know
it what a [ __ ] weird-ass currency it's
like it's so funny seeing the currencies
they're so [ __ ] like Hough and [ __ ]
okay
tie one huh
I'm out if I'll ever go to Taiwan I'll
feel reaches fun we're keeping on the
rack boy
top bottom on into your Jaffe
you have changed the name of you guys
from Bros to Jeff blink twice if you
think it's a good idea
[Music]
how many times have I died though for
real this raft [ __ ] sucked dick
honestly
[Applause]
can we get a 420 hop donation uh-huh oh
my god
uh-huh oh [ __ ] what should we name the
raft Jeff Jeff don't die on me Jeff no
we can still do this Jeff we're gonna
make it through this Jeff come on Jeff
don't you die on me don't you die on me
jet you're my only raft I love you like
you are my child Jeff come on boy
don't break on me now
[Music]
nine deaths now zero death vero
definitely a right answer that was a
trick question
god damn it guys Andy Milonakis I'm gay
confirmed here on the PewDiePie channel
Andy Milonakis comes out as a homosexual
that's all right
I'm gay - Andy what are you single we
should date oh my god oh my god oh no ha
[ __ ] I didn't god damn it what the [ __ ]
happened to you go I really need to heal
[ __ ] you're distracting me with your
gayness A&E for [ __ ] sake
oh [ __ ] I'm getting licked this is super
gay I love it
oh my god what the [ __ ] is that let me
just heal okay I'm just
ah ah stop licking me for [ __ ] sake
zero deaths zero deaths everybody zero
deaths
we got 69 . 69 from blasts hi hi thanks
for always having me laugh on good and
bad days first time I ever gotten
watched a stream loving it sorry for
kinky no no oh my god what's happening
what is happening you guys need to stop
distracting me I'm loving it sorry for
hating me watch you be a tease that's
awesome thank you guys cruciate it I
need to stop dying zero deaths I mean
zero deaths Sarah Dessen everyone know
we're about don't worry about counting
that [ __ ] sake for [ __ ] sake guys
for [ __ ] alright let me just run away
from this guy
I am it am I at the bottom of a [ __ ]
pool great don't you just love running
at the bottom of a pool it's like comma
comma come on get up get up get up
yes [ __ ] can't swim this is like that
episode of [ __ ] not episode it
follows in the end when they the thing
in the pool let me just take a [ __ ] let
me just take a [ __ ] everyone I mean dire
need of a [ __ ] taken you don't sound too
good man should be he'll run hey yes a
toilet where I come from
Oh was a tight gap it also reminds me of
that music video with that die Oh
well now I've seen it all how the [ __ ]
do I get out of here
dude don't [ __ ] swear
what a good video they're going to laugh
at you
what was it title then let's take a
little shower ah ah this is just like
that one time with that one girl that's
all I'm gonna say about that oh my god
oh they're sexy how nice this game got a
lot more chill I like it what the [ __ ]
was that
our greatest Jam okay well if it's
jammed
put it on your sandwich that's what I
always say oh look I'm making blood
finger bear footprints okay not that one
maybe not that one how about this one Oh
No
and maybe it's just blood pudding you
know I guess that's still technically
blood for [ __ ] sake what am I supposed
to do here anyway appreciate all the
support you guys are enjoying the stream
if you guys can help me
it's a door here that's jammed as well
Jessica where are you talking about I'm
inside the die music video with the [ __ ]
should be a window here somewhere I can
jump out of talking about the lifeguard
that's really nothing here
make the janitor mad leave the pool boys
locker room okay that would make sense
let's check all the bathrooms
there's nothing here though okay we
found it
this Texas isn't it we found it cool
thanks guys
hey look it's it's schmeckel my favorite
youtuber uh and we got we got wait we
got another [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm sorry Whitney grim tits
did my other intonation go through I
didn't see it I saw it
Whitney I think so appreciate your
Whitney God are getting chase again
aren't I
I'm not going to [ __ ] die this time
I'm getting real [ __ ] sick or die let
me go
[Music]
[ __ ] why are all the goddamn doors trap
here we go
maybe we can play outlast on one of
these computers that would make sense
right you need to get to the second
floor okay no okay let's see head no no
chilling is world hands linen got them
got them
no chilling a no hands linen what could
it mean zero deaths everyone batteries
when the mornings gone in you can't go
uh batteries kept Falak schools now I
know where I'm never gonna put my
[ __ ] kids that look on the other side
okay okay we are on sort on the second
floor oh my god ah it's raining blitz
hallelujah it's raining blood yeah boy
there on earth beer up ah ah feels so
good it's so nice and refreshing it's
warm it's 37 degrees
where I'll ever go later my name is Jeff
this is wonderful having a great time
my name is dead meme guys haha that's
the thing the Jeff meme can never die
it's it's holy or unholy should I say oh
wow oh wow yes ah this reminds me of
Evil Dead the remake I really like to
remake a lot of people don't like it
because they didn't use a lot of special
effects
they had like a part in the end where
there's raining blood and they literally
just had people up in the trees with
[ __ ] spraying blood I don't know it's
just so cool I recommend that movie
watching it with friends is really fun
last llama laughs man some I hate horror
but turn this [ __ ] into a comedy ha ha
sorry donut again for the laws cuz I'm
in a good mood food is young and in love
food what am I saying sorry for
distraction 69 69 I don't know what I'm
saying
GG well played thanks last appreciate ya
ok
holy [ __ ] this is really cool the game
gets cooler and cooler I gotta say I see
a lot of negative comments about the
ending of the game I'm really curious I
think the idea I'm super impressed by it
DJ's DS Robo TV love your content and
Aussie youtuber go to sleep Australia I
should also do a schooi beer alcoholic
beverage I'll do a schooi next time one
main step for you teach these Robo TV I
don't want to use the cam because it
looks so [ __ ] cool with a blood rain
how you doing buddy looking good
seems [ __ ] possible to see though
here we go
[Music]
a lot of people died here a lot of
people died in this game thinning is
good okay
I'm looking for I love the ending of the
first outline I thought it was cool
maybe I'm a little biased good meme you
guys probably someone understood what
I'm [ __ ] oh my [ __ ] god what
happened
oh god it's someone in here no no no no
no no no no no no no no close the door
close the door close the door closing it
and lock it in can I can't lock in got a
thousand rupees is it Ruby hi Felix been
watching since 1 million subs it was fun
to watch you grow you inspired me to my
dreams move to move from Russia with my
boyfriend and make music thank you so
much I also make guitar covers on
YouTube super happy check them out
that's awesome dude that's cool I'm glad
I'm glad you got your [ __ ] sorted out
thank you so much Syd hi win hi me and
my brother watch your show for 4 years
still love it keep up the gameboard love
for Norway you guys are so nice thank
you said shout out to you and your
brother my ego is like 10 times
exploding after these live streams
because you guys are so nice ok I think
we're gonna have to go to where this
[ __ ] make it a high five
tough but I'm on
hi Felix from Sydney Australia why is
Australia not asleep yet that's all I
want to know oh god [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god this is creepy oh my
god okay don't spoil and a nice I didn't
see anything
I think someone is in here [ __ ] why did
I go here there's a door go go go
yes yes Jesse says close close whoa who
is in here with me I don't want to know
[ __ ]
Oh someone has been here recently
yes we tried to get it back okay for the
enemy but they wait Lin
uh have you seen her cute boys don't
touch me please the lucky ones
they kill get out we have to leave we
have to go good talk man
I'm having some delicious nuts I'm sorry
for eating just got a state energized
[Music]
sorry let me just finish this pack oh
[ __ ] man I should eat something less
crunchy tonight I'm sorry no no
god damn boss this is not
family-friendly I don't like batteries
when the bottom got in G so singing song
hey [ __ ] what up dog Thank You Jess
when you're here things low when you're
so good
hope my freestyle is [ __ ] good man
what can I say
back uh what was that the [ __ ] was that
[ __ ] I don't like to school men
I'm never sending my kids to [ __ ]
Catholic school that's for [ __ ] sure
I'm saying them to Satan school is that
a thing can we make that happen um what
am i doing
what's with all the empty rooms
subscribe to pewdiepie by the way in
case you haven't subscribed make sure
you subscribe to my channel upload
videos um hey we're the most streamed on
youtube right now how about that that's
cool you guys are watching the worst
let's play on YouTube because I'm
[ __ ] stuck all the [ __ ] time god
dammit I don't know where to go why not
here why not why not help me this part
has two big screamers thanks for
spoiling it now I'm turning down my
volume a little bit I'm just kidding I'm
not [ __ ] I'm scared of no screamer do
you think I'm [ __ ]
for [ __ ] sake guys help me help me
please
oh my god we got another turtle chips
thanks again man preciate you have a
good night thanks for watching you're
you're [ __ ] awesome really appreciate
it here we go for [ __ ] sake okay
Jessica Jessica Jessica it's Jessica
remember Jessica I just remember Jessica
no no no I don't want that but what
oh that I'm fine I'm fine listen we're
fine we're fine we're fine [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] an inch now I like this check
the computers okay okay okay you're a
little late with that comment
[Music]
are there more computers to check I want
to still let I want still lick throwing
the computers and watch porn
what a great suggestion guys you're
always so hilarious oh excuse me
[Music]
you gotta go to gaming dot youtube.com
slash Cooper and you can become a
sponsor what the [ __ ] where do I go now
I'm going to run out of batteries if
this continues check the other computers
but I don't see it oh there it is
[ __ ] I'm blind I'm legally blind I can
see you Oh God
rage against the machine is that you
what was the other thing on your screen
nothing just messing around last bro who
needs sleep for his life
so I'll read it later who has control
what is this
community support hope and pray is for
depressed anxious Catholic believe you
can't masturbate of course you're going
to get anxious you just need to rub one
out you know if you're feeling not
alright just rub one out it's Felix its
Felix remember that song actually please
so that was a bit weird if you're not
feeling alright then just rub one out
it's feeling it okay pulse well I'm
getting great footage here guys
[Music]
I have a feeling my SD card it's going
to get corrupted in the end that's the
real plot twist that's a real thing you
go through everyone everything and
they're like where's your revenues oh
yeah I got I got it right on the disk
corrupted no that would be the true
horror of a youtuber Hey
thank you for opening the door more
computers okay all right I'm trying to
check all the computers what the [ __ ] I
swear I check them all
did I miss one did I miss one
hello thanks to all the mods by the way
for commenting all the spam really
appreciate all the help and also
appreciate all the mods not spamming
what do I go here dude you really can't
run long high from von Guericke de
Australia Australia go to sleep oh oh oh
oh what is this oh oh no oh no oh I'm
getting out of here man
[ __ ] I'm walking in circles now I'm an
idiot did she just say family friendly
do I need to go back there
exit boots
oh yeah boy we're getting out of here
zero death this is a zero def
playthrough has never been done before
Oh for [ __ ] sake huh yeah I get that I
get I'm not alone here you said it like
a gazillion times Australia never sleeps
hello you little [ __ ] getting tired of
her I don't like her it's too much
[ __ ] with me
Hey ah for [ __ ] o for free god damn
it that's fine that's fine at it I don't
like her anyway I don't like her anyway
right now that's locked great good job
Felix
good job Felix you you've really done it
this time boy does anyone go to Catholic
school that's watching this give me a
little tip I need a little tip ah dog no
you will not lick me oh [ __ ]
oh we're back in our work me I'm curious
how much of the game is it is left I'm
really cured
we're back in the rain hallelujah
hallelujah because to me blood rain
seems to be an indication that you know
hey looking good man looking good Oh Oh
[Music]
God
ah [ __ ]
oh god they're coming they're coming
they're coming good
crawl under crawl under barn you're
crawling [ __ ] I can't fit I'm too fat
[ __ ] I've done it now boys [ __ ] do you
think it's safe do you guys think it's
safe
I don't know if I trust this man ah [ __ ]
oh okay ah oh it's really bloody outside
i forfeit dance yeah blah drop all
batteries hahaha very yo Felix I go to K
Pollock and this is what it [ __ ]
feels like ha ha
great I bet
wow that oh wow how nice
can we exit here so anywhere to go I
feel like there's this out here it is I
see it now oh you know what I wasn't
actually supposed to go there
oh my god it's tree people
oh [ __ ] it's cha Oh
[ __ ] its tree people after me
[Applause]
uh-oh oh oh no oh
tsch bad rose
this is real bad yeah we're doing it now
you know when your barrels are helping
you you know that so when you know
you're [ __ ]
run pants what the [ __ ] are you talking
about spank him
great suggest Cindy [ __ ] throw your
[ __ ] tree schmuck out and she kicked
me run run run run ah ah
Jason bison Oh No where do we go
he'll helio i'll have any manners [ __ ]
here ah go back no don't hurt me I'm
Swedish
watch me ah ah run you're sucking
[ __ ] cow Wow [ __ ] man I don't want to
keep running I'm running at us jump yeah
come on whoa yeah Mitch yeah go go go go
what do I go where do I go go
Wow
[Applause]
hell yeah that was [ __ ] awesome hell
yeah
that's what I'm [ __ ] talking about oh
god keep going
[ __ ] yeah oh my god
minecraft minecraft man alright let's go
in
painter Jess all right let's do a quick
quick run to go through the amazing
support a thousand Danish hello from
Denmark my sister love you swearing a
Swedish that's fun about tell you me
when you say food they also go buy some
sour cream and onion chips I
I love sour cream and onion ship they're
the [ __ ] best saying Thank You MC P
95 aspiring writer New Zealand fifty are
you able to shout out the non-existent
country of New Zealand I didn't know
that was a country how about that we
have sheep and lots of grass bless you
though dude I also went to get that cook
that catalytic and it contained a lot of
hot students oh hello there Perry Sammy
Ramadi hey Felix awesome stream been
watching you since 2013
even the only constant thing in my life
I rely on and I can rely through all
this time you've been there for me
through everything thank you for all
your hard work love you man oh that's so
nice you guys are so nice if you guys
want to join the chat go to gaming
dot-com slash you [ __ ] gaming dot
youtube.com slash PTI gaming dot you
[ __ ] I don't know whatever [ __ ] how do I
get it back - there we go alright let's
keep playing
thank you guys for all the support
appreciate you love you will smack your
ass
and a non-sexual violent way just in a
daddy or five way if you know what I
mean that's right oh wow this place
they're they're decorating early for
Christmas huh it's beautiful beautiful
ornament go to Catholic school one sub
equals one prayer nice Jesus I've been
waiting for you what oh [ __ ]
Oh God Jesus no Jesus J says why why why
Jade's dead take me with you [ __ ]
take me with you on your adventures I
would but I am busy holding this camera
man sorry oh sorry I'll walk around next
time sorry there you go you're sponsored
by go in a gaming dot youtube.com slash
P type and hit the sponsor button that's
how you sponsor appreciate you guys love
you guys so much I saw something in here
Jessica love Blake okay
I think this game is amazing I love it
this the unit take away older getting
stuck bits it's [ __ ] cool man you
know finally I can relate to Jesus okay
maybe this one Jessica Jessica Jessica
bandages yeah Jessica good thing though
blood came on those bandages good dog
girl oh wow
somebody's [ __ ] lock the door can you
stop locking the goddamn doors stop
locking the doors didn't it sound like
they unlocked it they did what the [ __ ]
last bro you know when you see a bloody
Chris Vegas Bennett use the deal what
the [ __ ] I'm not gonna say that last
shell okay geez sesh yes no wonder my
[ __ ] outlet videos get demonetised
honestly [ __ ] all the religious [ __ ]
and all that but not everyone's is
getting demonetised how about that
everyone Oh what happened oh oh game got
stuck oh it's just it's is still working
Magnum my slug booty pie
what is the music you play all the time
out les crashed what what wait a minute
wait a minute the game crashed the [ __ ]
oh god don't tell me I lost my save no
no please
epic they just gave me 5.5 pounds thank
you thank you Pepe bless your soul what
the [ __ ] it crashed that what the [ __ ]
man god damn this is so weird what what
do I do
wait a minute give me one second
all right it's working is it working
what here come on man
it crashed because you're trash wow
thanks
hey Antonio the well that was awkward
yeah it was but you know what there are
gaps the game just demonetized you [ __ ]
man
it happens to the best of us
let me get the chat back oh my god I'm
sorry hundred percent apologies sorry
sorry gomenasai gomennasai what
different it's a que les don't worry
okay
I was joke okay thank you so much that I
appreciate all the nation's very kind of
you lies
this is why I play on console oh yeah
okay all right sure sure buddy sure you
know that [ __ ] can happen on [ __ ] any
it comes oh okay I mean even ya know you
don't know what you're talking about
okay batteries when the mornings gone in
you're saying a son a birthday yet I'm
alone enable town or porn crafter but
they're here
buttery yeah for Farnell I get mail it's
about 30 era coming to torn battery your
sorrow baby time for next line away with
it
come on sharp or little anger well I
guess have a great day everyone Oberon
and I were having a great Sunday play
watching me play some outliers we're
gonna play some more games after this
one um the Stalin guy hey it's the
sullen guy everybody the celling guy I
do hair tutorials I did two bids on your
awesome hair please mention and
subscribe check out the sullen guy I
actually saw those videos they were
pretty good have you have you done on
the my latest haircut I guess not but
that's cool appreciate your video
student
[Music]
get Genesis oh I am now a sponsor am i
cool yet yes you are anyone who's a
sponsor is cool all right let's try and
not get the game crashed now I'm not
gonna walk that way I'll walk this way
don't crash don't crash
don't cry oh my god oh my god don't
crash don't crash don't crash don't
crash on me boy see you a cupcake thanks
for joining the stream don't crash don't
crash don't crash please don't crash am
I looking for a book or something a book
on how to not crash got it
what's the music it's [ __ ] farting
it's a mace oh [ __ ]
always just follow one side always works
you can't [ __ ] up I [ __ ] off okay maybe
you can maybe you can [ __ ] up [ __ ] I
need to work on my stamina dude it's
pathetic
all right we're sticking with our
strategy strategy oh god is that real no
no no no no no no no [ __ ] [ __ ]
nah [ __ ] that [ __ ] stop [ __ ] this is
getting really creepy
Oh No Lord forgive me everyone is asking
how to sponsor you to go to gaming dot
youtube.com slash beautif I really
appreciate everyone becoming a sub
becoming in our looks campaign okay
we're back here wait I'm not supposed to
go here where am I
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa faith the
history of faith everyone know I
remember its vault boy today in Sweden
which is like the biggest drinking
holiday so I figured I'll pop some
whiskey by the end of the livestream I
have some Swedish whiskies from the last
livestream can't carry any more bandages
exploring the path of joy great
no I did not scream like a little girl
shut the [ __ ] up you prick you scream -
okay shut up
ss why you had to yell at me like that I
want a dick hey it's a sister Scott
Purcell your boots you opted your gear
list again for all your new racy stuff
and many thing wait what sigh what
thanks Bruce Thank You salary I
appreciate ya you're gonna make he's
gonna make a new one with blond hair do
you have a hairstyle you will recommend
the new races stuff on many many things
for tweeting out the link earlier it's
cut personal how the [ __ ] do I get out
of here that's a good question that's a
great question hey how about
okay how about here just follow the
light hey follow Jesus don't let the cat
nipples grow what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] Oh
fun there are no handle that devil must
get springy a latina my God my God
oh oh oh oh that's right don't touch me
you crazy son of a [ __ ]
oh we're back here oh how would that
make sense oh look how nice
we're back in the bloody rain everyone
or black in the bloody rain
oh it's blocked so it's my boot
maybe we can push this somewhere
reckless gaming stuff hey piers been a
bros since the Fano days would be cool
if you could shout on my channel we'd
love it good luck without last I bet it
the other day the reckless gaming stuff
alright check out the record gaming
stuff I guess
appreciate your man appreciate all the
support what is happening what's
happening is moving on its own what is
happening it's glitching out what the
it's happening okay we're free okay we
can go now
hey did it even if you can't donate I
really appreciate everyone just watching
this scream I can't believe there's over
90,000 people that's [ __ ] awesome I'm
having a lot of fun I hope you guys are
enjoying it as well that sounded very
excited I'm having a lot of fun everyone
as you can tell god I just want Jessica
to die at this point
just leave me alone leave me alone
recharge [ __ ] my ass is asleep again god
damn it I've been sitting too long oh
god it's bad interact
oh go go go go go go go go go go
okay okay okay don't pick that clothes
go where is he
my god it's scaring the [ __ ] out of me
[ __ ] we're a [ __ ] it coming from
shut up it's freaking me out too much I
don't like it what happened to the
stream did we break it it's not updating
anymore for me all they're upstairs and
they're coming down Oh
better hurry up the gross where do we
put it where do we put it where do we
put it whatever put it there
where do I put it oh great they're here
hi guys hi yes
some guys just keepin it blind Thanks
preciate you well that could have gone
better where do I [ __ ] put it
where do I [ __ ] put it where the
sounds is so scary put it in the place
it belongs great you know I'm dead now
again right there there I had it in the
right place are you kidding me go go go
go go go go go go go
yes yes yes yes that's what I'm [ __ ]
talking about oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] ah ah jump oh no I'm
getting tired of this
go run yeah go ahead and [ __ ] up don't
[ __ ] up the [ __ ] up don't [ __ ] up oh
[ __ ] what No
where am I yeah ah no zero des I haven't
died a single a single time I haven't
done a single time
Oh oh my god my heart my heart will go
on man
[ __ ]
[ __ ] em yeah I'm legit [ __ ] myself
[ __ ] I'm so focused right now come on
Felix come on you can do this come on
man
okay don't [ __ ] hit me when I'm on
this [ __ ] thing yes okay ah no a
minute whoa hey hey hey the police if
that [ __ ] no I haven't died 48 times
shut up [ __ ] man god this is intense I
just got to be fast come on
run like the wind
go go god damn it boy
this is some [ __ ] Mirror's Edge
running [ __ ] [ __ ] jumping across god
they're right behind me I can hear them
jump go go
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass licking
[ __ ] oh god just I'll run and lose right
in her titties that's not good
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] ah you ass hole
oh [ __ ] Eddie head Novato I just
remembered I had an appointment sorry
just remembered I gotta take a [ __ ] [ __ ]
ah just great keep chasing me but see
how much this game wants me to have a
[ __ ] heart attack
I can't let's take a [ __ ] let's take a
[ __ ] rose Oh God
is it in here I feel like I should have
hidden in the toilets
ah stop that what the [ __ ] oh my god
what happened
[ __ ] Jesus [ __ ] Oh God
[ __ ] duck a [ __ ] a duck oh my god Oh
wrong way [ __ ] run like sanic they did a
little later day-day the Deaf count zero
that's correct
all right why why the [ __ ] did I go in
the [ __ ]
which one should we take a [ __ ] what you
see oh my god there's a father up above
man he's looking down in love so be
careful little eyes what you see Oh No
Oh be careful
Oh okay careful little man sweat shop hi
I understand what I was supposed to do
I'm so I realized too late
supposed to crawl understood the other
one [ __ ] oh this is intense man I can't
do this for too long I'm gonna die I
swear I'm gonna have a premature death
ha Felix died of horror game you know it
wouldn't be so bad I could I could die
right now that'd be all right not a bad
bad time you know so relaxing yeah okay
I'm supposed to crawl right
[Music]
zero next everyone
zero dead so we're almost out a hundred
thousand holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay here we go
[Music]
what you say
ah oh my god let's go [ __ ] it's locked
you're not evil like shut up just
confused shut up
go go go go I'm not hiding I promise
just chillin chillin out maxin relaxin
all cool don't I know I don't need help
don't need help I feel great I feel
fantastic
oh hey thanks for that [ __ ] oh the
sound is killing me holy [ __ ] hundred
thousand people watching
that's [ __ ] incredible oh Jesus hey
America Hillary Clinton Hillary Clinton
a hundred thousand people four hundred
Hillary Clinton everyone Hillary Clinton
help Hillary Clinton hell yeah jessica
is a [ __ ] this is all your fault great
thanks my nipples honestly are itching
like [ __ ] crazy I'll never like you
hug okay cool don't want to hug anyway
whoa if if literally everyone watching
right now went to gaming dot youtube.com
slash PewDiePie and hit sponsor then I
could literally just remove ads from all
my videos anyway and I'd be fine
that would be great thank you good get
go to gaming dot youtube.com slash boot
pad everyone do it top of the morning
thank you guys so much for all the
support you guys are [ __ ] awesome
love you guys I will lick your ass
honestly I do some kinky [ __ ] [ __ ] where
do I go I'm stuck now I can't be stuck
now can the camera chill I'll never let
you wear Uggs
is that it [ __ ] what do I do
what do i do we just go out it's jammed
that roof Cham Serena's ceiling MIT can
you start with a [ __ ] camera Jetta
Jesus Christ Mike there's a window I see
it now
subscribe for dank memes everyone ah
come on
ah having a great time everyone hope
you're having a great Sunday having a
great time everyone in the blood rain
feels great how do I go down am I not
supposed to where am I supposed to go
then
what
what are you doing
what's he doing
this way
wait what what the anxiety is through
the roof yeah this is [ __ ] intense
this part but why don't I just drop down
there why doesn't he know when I drop
down by Sunday on my life I'm having a
lot of fun this is cool jump down jump
down help I'm stuck I'm doing push-ups
what yeah
hello from Russia P is gonna be modern
your stream
I'm also youtuber with 5 million subs
hell yeah mr. low low low low low low
low scare hope you're not trolling
there's so many people in Russia [ __ ]
watching YouTube and [ __ ] help what do I
do
stuck even here shut up I am jump shut
up shut up shut up professional gamer
everyone Peter pie here live streaming
oh god [ __ ] [ __ ] this is bad it's just
real bad jump oh my god [ __ ]
platforming game all of a sudden all
right what do we go now down there
that's a bit high isn't it up here here
we go nice holy crap
so many people in Russia [ __ ] yeah I
sometimes I say great things and you are
not supposed to quote me for that
can we write a minecart down that be
[ __ ] cool
what do I do
what the [ __ ] do I do now again that's
right I came from here right yeah I did
okay I was just making sure no I did
wait what now could you see id can play
say professional gamer okay shut up you
guys don't have to put cyber bullying me
alright I really don't appreciate I'm
against cybernetics Oh
well then easy easy this game is soap
battery pop buy out the lesson nice when
the morning's gun and you wear a thong
berries whoa oh did it's a party on the
screen for a second ah that's right it
oh jeez last okay before we continue for
this last all right I got uni tomorrow
need my beauty sleep good night good
night last a prick [ __ ] appreciate
thanks for staying up I appreciate
everyone watching staying up late [ __ ]
this though I'm just gonna go and
remember I have uni as well tomorrow
[ __ ] can't touch this can't touch this
can't touch this can't touch this can't
touch this
ah where the [ __ ] do I go
press age to heal now it's not really a
great time for that go go Bonnie go
you're a [ __ ] ho how many times are
these [ __ ] gonna change me go go go
go go for [ __ ] sake come on come on we
can do it you can make it if we try ha
just the two of us you and crawl for max
yet yeah hell yeah
yes yes hell yeah that's what I'm
talking about
[Music]
[ __ ] yeah easy this game is easy
I can't believe haven't done a single
time can you believe that can you
believe that pain Oh healing this is
[ __ ] running from dying simulator oh I
guess that's a horror game for you
alright if we not have more room for
bandages okay wait we're back here an
elevator and a llama
let's go up the a lobotomy for my
girlfriend
I'm coming Marzia coming to save ya
what's happening it's not moving
what's happening
no no the [ __ ] sake I'm so [ __ ] tired
of this Lima is like super fast on I'm
an empty foot if I'm a new tic you [ __ ]
I'm tired of these [ __ ] ass
I'm tired of these [ __ ] plane
people on this [ __ ] game why do
they hate me so much
I love plants I wash the plant one time
it's a long story
don't really have time I'm running out
of salmon a man
look I can't even [ __ ] run anymore ah
funny hell
spring nodding yeah blah coughs ah hey
are you doing
[Music]
by
ah yes [ __ ] up so [ __ ] hard
I would [ __ ] them I would spread their
[ __ ] ass and I was sick of my notes
right in there and I would do [ __ ] you
that was way more disgusting than needed
but I'm sorry but jess is dead okay
she's good
I mean Lin good whatever Wow well zero -
on a [ __ ] roll
ah
[ __ ]
damn on oh my god oh my god five hundred
feet eight out of eight
you missed that 250 dollar donation
where are you two kidding me no I didn't
but that's the [ __ ] Philippine II
calm down but I appreciate it though
thank you
so I just really want to focus on the
game
what do I do jump
[Applause]
[Music]
okay we're killing it for us
Raquelle na go to gaming don't
youtube.com slash PewDiePie and
subscribe in that way I can just not
have ads anymore that would be [ __ ]
awesome think about that zero deaths
zero death everyone batteries if you're
enjoying the stream I really appreciate
it
this is [ __ ] awesome we're in the
mines now welcome Gillette fir know it's
there any place there's not a [ __ ]
[ __ ] thank you for reminding me of
the battery guys cuz I heard oh [ __ ]
it's her
their battery their oh my god this is
the [ __ ] most intense livestream I've
ever done this game is so fun to does
not give you a [ __ ] break does it we
could probably squeeze through that I
can't we nope
thought I was good at squeezing through
tight holes I'm 12 ish just confused
where is this story going am i insane
that's probably it hey a torch
we got a 500 new region hey Mohammed's
back at it again what up my Hamish don't
have a good time mister don't have a
good time to watch the rest oh don't
have time to watch the rest but a really
important favor to ask we'll listen
please play Nico play Nico okay I'll
check it out man
why don't I get that torch instead of
this [ __ ] Oh No it's fake right yeah
it's a faker
everyone's becoming sponsor I will suck
your ass - coming in early captain great
this place is falling the [ __ ] apart Jax
but ice is better thank you appreciate
it
deuces I do agree
dude that apps all he got skinned he got
[ __ ] skinned man that's that's very
nice that's very nice
oh man I can't believe this [ __ ] over
a hundred thousand people watching how
y'all do it
I can't believe it it's [ __ ] weird
unreal unreal guys I'm Madani love your
videos trying to playing outlets to the
DLC it's [ __ ] awesome
I hope yeah I hope this one gets a deal
see that'd be [ __ ] cool battery
batteries
sorry I gotta open up there we go
battery year they've order some fan mail
it's about done but that is all right
where's that [ __ ] I mean our girlfriend
hello what was that neigh go neigh don't
hurt me please
[ __ ] about to get real
oh god what's gonna happen open open
hi okay we're fine
where do they go what what what
you can't just insta kill me oh my god
Jesus Christ
dread pirate a hundred please don't suck
on my ass but things for much
entertainment over the air I'm off to
bed but keep doing what you do that's
amazing
thank you so much man have a good night
thank you for staying up and watching
this [ __ ]
it's got to be creepy watching this [ __ ]
at night I had to read spot that are you
thanks for insta killing me game I mean
zero death of course Sarah deaths zero
deaths everyone buck teddy it cosmic
YouTube I pity I love your content a
funny I'm watching enjoying the stream
can i be a mod cosmic youtube okay fine
appreciate you okay so wait we didn't go
here before we we went here
yep get the whiskey in pits late later
on later on we got a Oh God we got a
long day ahead of us best gamer ever
zero deaths that's right let's [ __ ]
write 7 a.m. waking up in the morning
gotta be fresh all right well I know
which store not to go in now thank you
game
yeah sorry there's no net glow we're
trying to figure out a lot of details we
spend a lot of time trying to get
everything sorted and unfortunately
we're still missing some components and
[ __ ] what's happening I don't like this
I don't like this at all this [ __ ]
mine sucks ass okay well I guess we're
just gonna start running now I'm gonna
start running now I really really got a
strong feeling about just running may go
run the other way you idiot
[ __ ] oh my god why is mine why am I not
playing Minecraft god damn it
all I ever wanted was to play Minecraft
hide hide hide I died I died I died a
Quentin I was going back to back to see
when I saw this dream decided was better
than dreams Quentin appreciation the
microphone on your cam will help that's
a good tip thank you forgot I had that
is it safe
Thank You Jack for clarifying no please
hi how you doing don't kick me ah what
did I said I said I had one [ __ ]
request nope I'm not fast enough
I'm so [ __ ] dead why are you filming
[ __ ] I'll be okay let's just film this
really quick for the youtubes zero
deaths everyone whoo
we're doing a zero def playthrough on a
licen case you're new I'm a pro gamer if
you haven't heard of me before I go by
the name of Jack spicy I I do
games I play all the games hey a baby
card that's nice let's go baby
I play all the games ever and I have
zero deaths so if I die we're going to
restart the whole playthrough again
that's the reason why everyone is
watching because I'm really good at
games I'm really really really good at
game I'm extremely talented it's a gift
it's a gift I had for a long time pimba
pimba what the [ __ ] shut up with the
Pemba when I perish 8u pimba good old
pimba I wish I was a pimp you know what
I mean
fainted yes hiding in the locker for no
reason
let's lock this
why would I do that there's nothing in
here
is there anything in here
whoa what the [ __ ] is happening let's
take it easy
they're right there they're at their
breasts oh my god
hey whoa maybe we need to push of course
we push baby backwards why don't you
guys tell me
you
I got it easy puzzle
thank you baby appreciate you no worries
a better problem okay if you've done
something I want you to tell me he's my
psychiatrist isn't he okay
gonna have nightmares yeah well me too
[ __ ] hell it's just scary to watch
because it's [ __ ] scary to blame in
alright let's reload Jesus Christ
you have to switch the track I already
did it you guys are [ __ ] delayed
holy [ __ ] so many people watching unreal
Unreal Engine 4 we need to sleep all you
need is a blessing boots oh you're not
going to sleep if you're watching this
anyway oh it sounds lovely down here oh
my god Wow nice how many people died in
this goddamn place
[ __ ] oh my god okay I want to get out of
here
I want to go back to bed [ __ ] I hate
mines they're so [ __ ] creepy look at
that ah what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] three monsters what have you
done to Lin first oh we are creatures of
appetite oh [ __ ] it's them [ __ ] girl
boy anger I'm gonna see it look it up
boo say look at that camo turn in this
world damn what the [ __ ] I can see her
Koosh don't tell max yeah the feelings
feelings
oh my feelings I just saw a vagina
halos welcome porn for Lord naked hiding
nothing I show my face
see oh wow oh no I don't want the tree
thing don't lick me again just don't
lick me again cuz you're ugly had that
lint
oh it's not true
what's happening oh you got rekt [ __ ]
hi Oh what are you kidding me are you
kidding me run you [ __ ] [ __ ]
whoa go Felix go go Felix go we can do
this all night long baby girl I've been
chased for 400 oh this way this way
aah god damn it I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm trying [ __ ] welcome all the
new sponsors are we nearly at the end
someone just wrote it what the [ __ ]
there we go
yes yes babies yes ah no no oh space
squeeze squeeze squeeze squeeze squeeze
squeeze squeeze squeeze don't touch my
nips yes oh god I got a splinter in my
necklace feels good though feels good it
feels good okay laughter yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
tops fun cool or shut up shut up shut up
oh that can't be good
this wires a wife those wires are alive
gonna have to swim underneath right am i
swimming oh oh well that didn't work
what's he'll [ __ ] what do I do guys I
thought I could swim underneath
maybe here I can't see underwater so
it's not that easy
oh I'm stuck watch No
she saw me didn't she Oh
titties [ __ ] titties man oh can you
not just swim you [ __ ] [ __ ] what do
I do
[ __ ] I [ __ ] up big time you have to
turn off the power maybe turn up the
power follow the wires and disconnect
okay
am I not dead yet I feel like I've died
like 20 times
[ __ ] okay [ __ ] today in just follow that
run follow the wires okay got it got I
got I got it
god I gotta get gotta get that boom boom
boom alright here's the wire
what do [ __ ] guys
why did you lie to me there it is yes
thank you thanks [ __ ] [ __ ] ain't
[ __ ] but hope I was right by the wires
are you kidding me my fun victims table
rob corddry moon n man of many hey Felix
massive fan we put a list of your gear
together on my website many of many many
of many tastes we just updated for new
new gear including a new sound board
we'd love to check it out I'll check it
out that's cool
I think I saw the other one it's very
impressive
and many of many ok let's see if I can
[ __ ] do this come on
come on guys we're almost there we're
almost by the end of the game we can do
this so I thought I would just swim
through there right but she just went
around what
Oh what are you [ __ ] [ __ ] my
nipples out I thought I'd turn them off
I turned it off they're not man I
[ __ ] suck zero deficit one zero des
don't worry about it it's a glitch which
don't count okay come on we got this
there's two of them what's the other one
that
[ __ ] I'm really used to Mike okay oh
that's what you meant
okay there's two switches great [ __ ] I'm
so [ __ ] train great [ __ ] this sucks I
don't even know where the other one is
come on
come on I meant held back there are you
kidding me oh [ __ ] I bet her puss is
super soggy right now oh cool
well that take care of that Sh [ __ ]
okay all right we know where one
switches so where's the other one
okay there's two cables oh I see
here they go so one goes here uh-oh
there's the cable I see it I see it back
today at okay okay KK KK where did the
wire go it's here okay all right we got
this bros we got this we got this - stay
focused stay focused Felix you got this
[ __ ] I'm nervous
I'm so [ __ ] nervous come on Felix
come on I feel the pressure man I feel
the pressure on my nipples they're about
to crush man that about to get [ __ ]
smoosh to death man come on come on yes
zero deaths [ __ ] come on come
on boys
Wow yes Sarah
mother [ __ ] man boys just now that's
what I'm talking talking about
push this [ __ ] [ __ ]
I see the hustle shut up shut your
[ __ ] mouth
ah ah ah oh my god I almost died
oh they'll happen there
there we go oh my god
and now we just pull it back right I
know I'm MLG guys I know my pro player
really appreciate all the support boy
how long do I need to put it down how
far do I need to pull
come on and go
it's question ten Oh No okay but just do
it for [ __ ] sake
unbelievable even Jax but I see can't
you see oh there that's right
not even wait why the [ __ ] haven't you
told me that my hair is sticking up like
that how long has that been the case
unforgivable good job not [ __ ] can we
cool eh
oh [ __ ] I hate when they just run it
straight into you mate
I don't like that man I'm getting tied
to pee as well this is bad being a dud
naked oh [ __ ] I don't wanna go down in
the water again the vagina blonde sir is
there huh oh all right where am i where
am i where am I 800 feet hold me now I'm
800 feet from the years knob doesn't
love you know like I do know that's a no
everyone that's it oh look dildos wow
how nice Go Go Go I'm a [ __ ] ho
Go Go Go oh wow got so tired of this
just leave me alone please
ah
ah go what are you doing yeah can we
take a stream pee break
please I'm going to pee myself run run
you [ __ ] run you're supposed to run
you're not running what are you doing
[ __ ] right there which way which way
which oh this way ow ow ow outfit up bat
up pep-pep
hit the hay hey where do we go we go
where they go oh oh my god a little
better
Oh
[ __ ]
[ __ ] ham oh okay
well I'm having a bad no she sees me she
sees me
don't touch me don't touch me don't
touch me I'm allergic to touching don't
touch me you can't touch me baby baby
baby [ __ ] come on come on go [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh god what am i doing with my
[ __ ] life at this point there's a
ladder there's a lot of this ladder yeah
see see see see says praise the Lord
praise Satan Almighty Oh feeling like
vaginas oh man guys if you want to use
the chat go to gaming comm slash sorry
gaming dot youtube.com I keep saying
gaming gaming dot you to become such
Peter pie you can watch the stream there
and you can hit the support button if
you want to use the chat oh boy
I'm gonna be if I survive all this I'm
gonna gonna have some whiskey min by the
end of this I'm gonna have some [ __ ]
whiskey what do I go now up always jump
buddy
can you shout out my boyfriend shout out
to your boyfriend the voice crack shut
up I've been talking for a long time
don't make fun of me
Thank You mods for doing a good job by
the way
appreciate you you love that stinky ass
match no I did not I did not no one
loves the stinky vagina hi hi ah what'd
I say about stinking vaginas what did I
just say ah [ __ ] took my [ __ ] body a
gay person she took my [ __ ] camcorder
what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my god what is happening what is
happening what's happening what's
happening what is this oh man
no no no what I'm beating you you just
got a boner
no I yeah tell me you don't know that
[Music]
not unless you answer wait wait Oh fine
then you have to give up if you see I
win I'll let you up okay you have to say
it you win okay
wait we're young you said to push over
Blake why well hey hey what the [ __ ] is
this what my god I'm I never hold the
hand of a girl before it's their bleach
here mustard ketchup
what that [ __ ] is happening
Wow 118 thousand people watching I hope
you're all having a great time
appreciate all your watching this is
[ __ ] awesome
what is happening I want batteries can
we look for batteries this is that's a
big jar of mayonnaise right there
I don't know why you have to be so
precious about it is she going to show
us our couch I asked first hmm I don't
know nerd
shut up you are what is happening if you
just came into the stream where I think
we would watch the end of the game I
just wanted to know you're a nerd too
proof that might say is in a girl what
what are you talking about and we just
hit down in 20 when I said that it's
[ __ ] awesome I'm really curious about
the ending of this game I really can't
wait to see it this has been a [ __ ]
awesome livestream so far come on boys
come on you think your parents are home
yet no usually not until after dinner
you think I could come over yeah sure um
Why Why What
like why do you want to come over she
wants to show the booty what does she
want to do with me I don't trust her
where she taking me to no Jessica oh
sorry we what are the two of you doing
in here
I would sorry Father Loudermilk we
stayed after school for journal we were
just leaving
let's step back into class please uh
you're not in trouble yet Blake you
don't want to get in trouble do you just
stay with me no I don't like where this
is going I want you to to tell me what
you were doing in here were you
misbehaving
do I need to call your parents Jessica
do I need to call your father again no
please I don't want to watch this my
friends nobody's in trouble yet does one
of you think you can make this right
Jessica Jessica look at me will you pray
with me will you help me make this right
stranger danger why don't you go along
home Blake did I interrupt something
between you two why doesn't it not want
me though then what did you want you
won't say you know shame is a gift from
God to let you know right from wrong
and what you want is very wrong go home
and pray Blake please stay Blake this is
awkward enough nothing's the matter but
I need you to leave us everything's okay
you can leave young man walk away
ah that's [ __ ] that come on we got to
get her out of there
we got to get her out of this somehow
[ __ ] where's my camcorder it's so quiet
oh my god is there nothing I can do I
feel so helpless music clients
responsibility good old Catholic school
huh Jesus Christ am I seriously just
leaving oh my god well I guess something
[Music]
looks like I'm staying looks like a oh
my god what the [ __ ] he's the monster he
has the same posture and everything ah
oh my god oh my god oh my god I don't
want to look
[Music]
you [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] her neck you think you saw
[Applause]
what's happening sorry what no but they
give me a goddamn break for one sec god
[ __ ] damn it I'm so sick of [ __ ]
running doggy
great hey sash right
[ __ ] which way do I go you have no
batteries great come on come on like you
know it [ __ ] this game is [ __ ] up
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god Lin rely what hey
titties
oh how they got bigger are you pregnant
I don't want to die here man I don't
want to babies and die here
I won't oh I won't let them kill you
hell yeah
good get a little get a little striking
lady now how about that Hey
guess I'm a winner after all in this
game huh oh my god okay on the topic of
what we were before if you're being
abused it's important that you tell
someone someone that you love will well
trust you and help you another problem
with the children especially being
abused is that they don't tell only 10%
people do so what the talk to someone
you love I don't know if they really
help anyone but I feel like it might be
some oh yeah
so much for nine months huh
I don't want our baby today I want the
baby to die okay
that baby is a child of Satan it needs
to go we must be by the end now if we're
will in again we have to get inside
before the baby comes
it's too dangerous before the baby comes
we can't why are we gonna have a baby
okay okay be careful
Bravo miss Bravo you be careful I'm
coming down I'm sorry good job you had
one job
all right so 133,000 people are gonna
watch me deliver a baby now that's great
that's great this is just what I wanted
all right uh uh fantastic I just okay oh
my god [ __ ] come on come on
no [ __ ] way are we seriously gonna
have to run again
are you [ __ ] kidding me where do I go
I can't even see anything ever [ __ ] I
can't
well now I don't have a dick so that's
great what the [ __ ] where am I supposed
to go
better than Elsa gameplay where do we go
I got a battery now because I died oh
yeah here we go shut up I'm trying yeah
you're pregnant in one day that's
definitely wrong oh you're fine you're
fine papa pips is gonna take care of ya
don't you worry papa parents got this no
prob Adam that [ __ ] just had to show up
in the worst [ __ ] time of all yes a
little further honey and family friendly
Felix is going to take good care of you
zero death so far for fun
my hand dogged me boy God guide my hand
how do you fall oh oh oh
not my penis not my penis no not my debt
what how did that happen
how in the world did that happen right
there is a guard hello Lou yeah [ __ ] you
and [ __ ] your God so I think you're I
think okay my name is Jeff this is why
we really need to be filming them
tittays tittes boy
all right Papa PIDs let's go let's go
deliver your baby you're gonna just lay
down somewhere you won't have a soda
where I don't see one where this doesn't
look like a path to me well that's how
you summarize this entire [ __ ] game
okay well maybe we should go that way
then
and great look at the tape
got Jessica fly no it just started will
find a grown-up but tell them what
happened
okay it's not my fault
okay
[ __ ] man stuck
oh my god this is so [ __ ]
where the baby at this is it is this
we're supposed oh great
why you gotta take a [ __ ] yeah she's
coming soon
we're fine we're fine everyone is dead
anyway the chapel we can take shelter
oh yeah the good old chapel better start
hitting record now oh my god the Thunder
okay let's go to the chapel everyone
oh my god
spark anymore
come on boys come on we can do this
we're almost there zero deaths I can't
believe we did the whole playthrough
zero deaths that's incredible I don't
believe it okay all right where were we
zip no there better not be anyone else
here
there we go it's baby delivering time
let's do it
sorry I'm sorry that's [ __ ] stupid I
hope I at that hey sorry I just need to
make it smart okay there we go
hey okay oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh you
need to lie down
yeah lie down and just breathe it's
gonna be okay can't do you can do it you
can do something's wrong you can do it
oh hey she's bleeding out of her cush
family pushin keep freezing okay oh
that's a lot of blood
[Music]
[Applause]
oh it's a baby I'm gonna name it
Satan oh she's gonna die [ __ ] sake lane
[Music]
we're good
I didn't get to play with her knees with
the fun great
what that [ __ ] great Lane I'm stuck with
a baby now are you happy family friend
everyone family friendly is she dead
yeah she is then great I'm stuck with
this [ __ ] noise machine now
[Music]
for delivering a baby I'm gonna name him
jacksepticeye uh Lin said you haven't
even kissed her yet
what like in Beauty and the Beast oh you
mean drama the play we're saving for the
like actual night uh-huh we are okay we
like
cheek kiss so like is she your
girlfriend
are you jelly Jessica tell me or else or
else what oh oh I got you again
[Music]
hey it's him
I didn't kill my children
I'm powerless again
the jars to store you have murdered bad
guys
God his God silent since the store the
birth who will he have if he destroys us
all who will he have left punished good
times I killed my children at least I
stood empty outside there's no more
perfect faith in that and still God is
silent
oh that's hard if you can
if you love anything at all cross no I
will never kill Jax but I see I love
handle well I wonder if I get to choose
but I expect he answers them oh oh not
in front of Jack Schmitt I see wrong I
want none of that in front of this chat
well chopper the money to you hey hey
look how curious Oh little spicy dicey
he's so cute all right well top of the
morning to you hey it's that guy this is
where I a quickly [ __ ] up because I
was wearing the headphones wrong
whatever all right go - holy [ __ ] 1000
144,000 people oh if you guys want to
use the shot go to gaming dot
youtube.com/scishow and click sponsor if
ed literally everyone goes I can I can
retire that would I can not put ads on
my videos anymore that would be great
think about that
Hey
the Sun is up we did it we did it zero
deaths everyone
Jack spit ACCJC hallelujah hallelujah
amen
do I get to kill him now sorry
[Music]
but I see dice I love it i hate's my new
champ he's gonna grow up and become a
youtuber one day oh it's a lot of dead
people here that I guess he killed
everyone hey is my seat excuse me sorry
come in come in come in through wait
what am I legit
oh okay oh why we're back in what what
don't kill the baby don't tell me what
the [ __ ] they do look around the cold
committed suicide
okay that makes sense try to find me
come over here where she a polish thing
thank you
[Music]
well I'll check it in a second I'll
never let you go you never let me go
well I mean Savior listen while I pray
begging he to watch and keep and send me
quietly to sleep watchful Savior wash
away all I've been wronged today help me
every day to be gentle gentle more like
thee oh is that it
I think we did it I think that was it I
think that was it everyone
oh my god and that's the Berra oh my god
what a great game first of all a polis
thing hype it's my friend Paul's
birthday is in May 16 s can you please
wait in my defense birthday a happy
early birthday pal hope you having a
great birthday okay now I really love
the game I thought it was so cool I
don't know why people didn't like the
ending I thought it was cool
super cool settings super cool theme
they really stepped it up from the first
game I thought for sure way more
interesting and yeah just a really fun
game
there's a jump-scare at the end and if
we went after the credits
and thank you guys for watching this
live string with me
uh we're going to play something else in
a little bit I'm going to take a little
break probably um oh yeah thank you so
much so much for watching and everyone
that supported this live stream is
[ __ ] awesome all the sponsors really
appreciate it and all that [ __ ]
you guys are [ __ ] awesome what love
you long time if I would really really
appreciate it if you guys
I don't know did the sponsor thing or
whatever gaming dock youtube.com slash
pity but become an hour looks captain uh
we're good [ __ ] now it's time to time to
P I would say time to do a little P and
then I'll go through some super chance
because I miss the [ __ ] ton of them
holy [ __ ] the shadows go crazy okay
creepy break I'll be right back I'll let
you watch
Edgar meanwhile
[Music]
you
all right back at it again
all hail the chair all right I was at
least 50 from me shy stone that's
[ __ ] awful
when Kevin in there
yeah uh edgers better than chair I
couldn't be bothered to move Edgar I
know we would never sit in place anyway
um okay I'll do some here's the plan
I'll do some super chats if you guys
want to or chat in general
nice shirt thank you I please say
something to my best friend Anton Yvan
in and Johnny vanning I love your ass
hair it's beautiful and uncharted last
legacy comes out in August okay that's
cool I look forward to look forward to
that [ __ ] boy sorry I disappeared for a
second there let me let me put me back
up here is that the right I feel like
I'm fat this feels more like my face
doesn't it can't tell peopIe you're
awesome been here since you first
started we'll be here to the end all you
feel live ninety one thank you for
always making my day that's cool thank
you
polygraph the theory is that the baby
was never real he's gone crazy and the
theory says the factory chemicals made
his life over he made his wife have a
false pregnancy I can see that it would
make sense if all if everything that
happened that wasn't the whole crazy
crazy thing was just in his head
so bad after all damn boy
hi Felix thanks for playing my tunes in
the live stream thanks for the Sava so
lots of people in the comments trying to
find this song could you do me a huge
favor and let them know my channel is
Buki oh I will
Jesus Christ it's going too fast now
[ __ ] you ki u ki yeh a why oh let's play
some now might as well cuz it was good
mix at lehigh pewdiepie love your
channel please keep it up
I want to ask you something really big
surprise awaits you if is visit my
channel ok I'll visit it in a bit it's
too many too many okay we're playing you
ki mix la
oh sorry I'm sana Hawaii chubby kid how
does one become a sponsor
I totally may like time gaming dodge
youtube.com slash pdaboy thank you
though appreciate bingo how you doing
thanks for the stream while deployment
hold on sir Thank You dingo men
appreciate you hope you can go to
philippines child
hope so too but miss confession or gamma
yes yeah please
we'll sit ups and litter to its maximum
tapers in EMS from idling population i
delayed match shout out to you I hope
you're having a great day a great time a
great life and I hope I don't like when
there's too many lyrics I'm gonna put
something else on
so I keep the senpai PewDiePie before I
meant for you to comment my name is Jeff
on my last video okay I will do that now
kiss you fast ah what can we listen to
this is good song my name is Jeff your
stolen it all oh my god can I have sex
with you yes mr. beast women bash say my
name
William bash venture she he's gonna
shout it pull at my ship whole Marsha
Paul suck a dick leonardgrill start
Norway spread in Sweden I bigger than
that the biggest lie ever told greetings
from Switzerland what up what the Mel
what up my swiss bros can i be a mod
place sorry we have too many now pure
max brofist profit P R max sub periods
want to say thank you for playing this
on my 24 happy birthday Janet Lopez will
you be playing pinstripe I hope if I get
time there's too many games coming out
right now but it looks [ __ ] awesome
hello from California Lynn P what up
California
good morning I should say hey from us
too soon will you continue streaming
more really funny enjoyed every minute
that's cool thank you God bald boy I
will I had a lot of fun no message it
was a prank keep up the good work jack
[ __ ] awesome preciate you kids have
been a huge inspiration for me if you
could check it it at our we super
appreciate it hopefully inspire someone
someday like you have for me all that
size Tiana M appreciate you check out
Dianna M everyone
bingo man Congrats in seven years - yeah
thank you
laughs I thought you left LEM I couldn't
stay away so high
[ __ ] sleep all-nighters with kids so
kids same don't can't donate more that's
alright you've done an amazing amount
I've really appreciated last why'd you
watch the whole thing hey family friend
of Felix can you give me a shot at been
with you simply in each day's also did
you actually sub to my last stream if
you I think if I said I did it I did but
yeah thank you man
yeah I'm subscribe
spotty ak-47 give me a shot I thought I
did hi pewds gutter here will I shave my
head today I reached my limit on the
other YouTube channel
lawl I'm homeless now stop go - gotta
search Gadar on youtube and subscribe to
gutter 70k I'm spinning my seller in
this this better be worth it
high-pitched hey Thank You Stephanie
appreciate you welcome Webster
wallflower and welcome lawrence
Partington welcome a brush to the zipper
good name's 400 I don't know what
currency that is but I'm sure ik I'm up
hits shake up his shake
shook dick well I will spank your ass
appreciate you
hi Putin you lastly livestream my
boyfriend had you give me a shout-out
and Ptolemy made a you're the best dude
love you oh that's cool
real Aang thank you fine hello nosh get
better and smell scare Felix you [ __ ]
Holloman Holloman what Safa are you ever
going to play League of Legends again I
I never really played League that much I
played other MOBAs but not League casts
and charity are hi Felix
thanks for the streaming would love to
see you come up with Marty on the
livestream someday that's a good idea
that's a good idea I would love to do
that I would check out your channel but
right now there's too many [ __ ]
people going on I'm sorry let me say to
my friend Jai is fat no you missed a
trillion donation oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] up in
there do some wallpaper engine what can
you do with it I have it what's
interesting about it Wall Street
Journal's fake news side cowfish
appreciate you okay I'll do a couple
more minutes of the super Chen and I'm
mana here do you love me yes I do
I became a sponsor because I was
promised a slick in Felix uh definitely
I there you go [ __ ] that was a pretty
cringe at Chan and Raylan you da bomb
Felix you Devon pills you da bomb
Cheyenne Cheyenne Cheyenne so you say
whoa Georgie potato of course Norway's
better than see what excuse no abort you
don't get any button okay fine
[Music]
that's what you get and imagine him
saying no Preston hedges hey Felix I
definitely can marry my hero Academy I'm
gonna watch it I'll wash it so many
people suggested it
Thank You Preston GJ awesomeness hello
from India India what up my endian
people Micaiah
brought brought a Brahmin are you going
to do more little night wears yes I am I
think you're making these videos been
around for six years
thank you for watching for 6 years
that's [ __ ] awesome thanks for the
shoutout
again 5 subs amazing 6 path of rain rain
and I love your avatar now if you can
hook me up with those anime girls that
will draw me like one of those French
guys I would be terrific one of those
Japanese girls I would draw me what what
yeah I got I got a lot of them hooked up
in the back don't worry about it hype
it's watching videos love your new stuff
can you give me an Irish brofist here it
comes
I'm kidding I'm breakfast ok sorry hey
what the mouth will you ever come to
Switzerland
never thousand fish having to go
crawling to sub and envy you I would
appreciate it if you help me reach out
at least hundred subs goal radish don't
you guys imagine yourself being
somewhere in a medieval setting butter
ground you are observing you got a sexy
voice man goal Radice go riotous magma
slug what's the year sound on your it's
Miku Miku I mean that's Anamika [ __ ]
I'm tired T on the beat hey pills been
offenses amnesia can you play my latest
beat on your channel I [ __ ] it I'll do
it
alright one more minute and then I'm
going to [ __ ] off for a little while
till I have
little beat playing some Lobby got a
[ __ ] missing like a shit-ton now ali
al Jumba head foods please tweet that
I'm cool ali m al Jimbo no you're lame
I'm just kidding thank you so much
though
[Music]
okay I'm gonna to finish up
Yusuf Morsi hip it's levy new counter
keep up can you please say Islam a Cal
is a noob Islam a Cal is a noob and
fatigue stat is on track right lowest is
this they're screening them in London
should I go they do it every Sunday once
a month I think I would love to do that
London is too far away I can't be
bothered Alissa McCain holy [ __ ]
yeah cube replace 500 can you try and
play moviestarplanet and get a boyfriend
on it well I have to play now Jesus
Christ [ __ ] hell
as good song I like it sorry I was going
to wait what was it called movie star
applying it what was that what is I game
I recognize it
[ __ ] it's moviestarplanet and ok I'll
check it out
cube replace thank you so much preciate
you turtle chips
damn it pits I need to upload so I can't
can't stick around too long run I just
wanted to leave a message to give me
some more support I'll make sure to come
back after uploading alright good luck
with your Apple eternal going to be
little nightmares it's a joke game I
love that game man that's cool good luck
good luck on your play
hey I would doing it more but I'm broke
that's alright I appreciate anything
still wanted to say hi that's cool
hey put some broke rules like I'm broken
I feel terrible ah keep being awesome
from Brisbane Australia I think that's
good hey hitting the sack in Australia
like good night Australia thanks for a
great stream love you bro ok I'm going
to take a little break now and then I'll
be back possibly try to look up
PewDiePie shooting star on YouTube it's
a new meme not sure if you ever seen it
I'll search it alright guys that's the
end of this stream thanks to all the
sponsors check out gaming dot Damian get
[ __ ] okay I give up
thank you guys you're [ __ ] awesome
you're more than anything I could ever
ask for
this is so fun love you guys seriously
brofist and someone just gave 100 Jesus
Christ okay breakfast
my big cheese we're ending this with my
big cheese for the brows love you Peter
pie you're awesome I'll take out Wall
Street Journal for you I've been
subscribed in a fence and Smosh was
number one oh [ __ ] that's a long time
ago I prayed you would be first to say
thank you big cheese
I so next playing some chill music for
gold riders thank you you're awesome man
and thanks for the subs guys brofist
gula ride is gratis thank you guys on
that note here you go blended
[Music]